a high school principal in texas has
been suspended over accusations that he
held quote extreme views on race and was
pushing critical race theory is another
example of parents being outraged over
what their kids are being taught or told
to do
and as i've stated now probably 50
billion times because we had bannon on
the show and he said he predicted this
we're now seeing more uh similar things
there's another there's a development in
the loudoun county school protests more
parents are seeking to join a lawsuit
over trans pronouns and that just goes
to show with along with mass mandates
critical race theory and critical gender
theory it's something well beyond one
thing right you hear from conservatives
all the time like oh critical race
theories in school i'm like well that
doesn't explain the protests of her
masks and the similarity between the you
know the the groups of parents that are
for or against these ideas it's like an
overarching culture war or tribalism so
how about we talk about all of this and
talk about potential alternatives and
with that we are being joined by chloe
valderre valderri yes valdez i said it
wrong uh you want to introduce yourself
hi everyone i'm chloe it's good to be
here i run a
really dope startup called theory of
enchantment we teach an awesome
anti-racism practice that is not
critically theory
um so that's what i do for a living and
i'm happy to be here we were having a
really awesome conversation about
nazis in world war ii germany and new
york and authoritarianism i think would
be real and
i'm just thinking like we should just do
this on the show yeah it's a really good
conversation yeah you know and i think
this is going to be a fantastic
discussion about all of this stuff
liberty
indoctrination school so glad to have
you thank you thank you for inviting me
absolutely happy to be here it's still
summer feels like fall especially in
this room guys yeah i know it feels cool
chloe and i are wearing our winter
jackets
yes happy to be here glad you're here
good to see you and i'm really hoping
now that he's mentioned that that i
survived the evening because i'm not
wearing my winter jacket but i think
we're we're adjusting oh yeah
i'm excited to have like a nuanced
conversation about critical race theory
and i really love the idea of having an
alternative to that kind of stuff so i'm
stoked for this evening yeah i think a
lot of like there's an interesting thing
where they use the phrase anti-racism
all the time yeah typically referring to
like crt ideas or whatever yeah and i
think most people in this country don't
like racism so yeah approaching that we
had we had papa john on you know papa
john's place and he kept saying that he
was anti-racist
but it sounds like a direct reference to
ibrahim kennedy and very specific
ideologies and we're like how do we
navigate that so yeah it'll be fun we'll
we'll we'll jump into all this stuff
we'll talk about all that but uh before
we get started my friends go over to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments from the tim cast irl podcast
this one and uh you will support our
journalists we just hired another
journalist we're looking to expand we're
also going on a big adventure into some
haunted towns starting tomorrow we're
going to be off for labor day because
trying to work on labor day is the most
insane thing we've tried it before it
just doesn't work yeah no joke it
doesn't work so like last year we're
like no i'm not taking a day off for
labor day and then like there's no news
no one's working nobody's talking you're
nobody wants to come on the show and i'm
like okay we're gonna we're taking late
so uh yeah we'll be going on adventure
and we'll be we'll be having that on the
cass castle vlog so thank you for all
your support don't forget to like this
video subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let's talk
about this first story i find
particularly interesting from just the
other day
cnn reports this texas high school
principal was put on administrative
leave after being accused of promoting
critical race theory
james whitfield principal of colleyville
heritage high school in dallas fort
worth was played in the dallas-fort
worth area was placed on leave monday a
month after a community member at a
school board meeting publicly accused
him of having extreme views on race and
called for him to be fired now the
school the school district says he
wasn't removed due to complaints by
community members
a july 26 school board meeting stetson
clark a former school board candidate
said he was concerned about the
implementation of critical race theory
in our district and named whitfield as
someone with extreme views on race
because of his extreme views i ask that
a full review of mr whitfield's tenure
in our district be examined and that his
contract be terminated effective
immediately clark said at the meeting
clark said a friend shared a letter that
whitfield sent to parents and students
last year which claims i'm sorry which
clark claims showed the principles
principle promotes a conspiracy theory
of systemic racism the controversy at
the high school and around whitfield
comes a number of parents and community
members across the state have urged that
critical race theory not be taught in
schools
so this is interesting we have we have
freedom issues and we have
culture war you know you've got a large
group of people in this country who want
to teach these things to kids i want to
get semantic for a minute um oh here we
go yeah yeah teaching critical race
theory what does that mean does that
mean that they are teaching it like the
philosophy of the critical race theory
like a communism philosophy of communism
course where they're teaching this is
the philosophy or are they
are they critically race theory teaching
students
about like
whiteness and things as part of like the
math class well there's a part of the
indoctrination of the teachings that's
my question what's the difference yeah
this description sounds very he says she
said so i don't know what to think about
this story
right and especially when they're even
saying the school like he wasn't removed
because of the complaints yeah oh but
but to go back to what you said real
quick and you can
well you can agree or disagree i'd love
to hear your thoughts on this i think
there's actually three different views
over what it means to teach critical
race theory and depending on the
politics of the individual involved and
what they're trying to achieve they'll
adhere to one of them so you have
teaching critical race theory which is
the left always jumps on this one and
says no one is reading derek bell and
kimberly crunch out of children this is
not happening critical race theory is
not a book on these schools no one
talked about it
conservatives aren't making that point
they're making the point more about
critical race applied principles which
is uh the next two there is the
implementation of the principles meaning
they take action in the schools that are
rooted in critical race theory and this
this idea of inequities and you know
marxist ideology so they're actually
applying the teachings of critical race
theory to the kids and having the kids
exist in this environment and then
there's teaching critical race there's
critic so that would be critical race
practice i would i would say and then
you have the teaching of critical race
theory through surreptitious means
whereas whereas in the math questions
they have injected theories of critical
race theories but it's not a quote right
yeah exactly like assuming that white
people are have or whiteness is a
problem how would you get from point a
to point b and you're like
they're like inserted as part of the
assumption is that the part of the
theory the theory is part of the
assumption the the example actually was
this viral video viral sorry photo where
it showed a picture of like a cartoon of
a white guy and a black guy and it said
you know daryl is a white man who gets
stopped by police 17 times every year
you know daryl is a black man who gets
stopped 236. what percentage you know
yeah so they do things like that that's
very surreptitious but that's that's the
third one that's that or that's the
second one i mentioned where it's like
they're just
putting these ideas uh uh
into play i consider that process or
also is that practice
it seems like a type of practice that's
where they're like teaching the thing
what critical race theory claims but
doing it not through the books like you
don't know you're learning it and then
what i what i mean about the third way
is when they say things like progressive
stack and the teachers are like i want
all the kids to say their you know their
race and what they feel yeah yeah yeah
so there's like differences so that is
that is the definition of praxis is no
one knows that it's happening you're
sneaking it in under the radar you're
not standing in front of the class and
reading derek bell and kim kremer lee
grenja
kimberly yeah
it just means theory and practice yeah
it's applied it's exactly what we call
it critical race applied principles
that's praxis and how uh common do you
think the praxis is as opposed to the
the other
how would you describe the other one
where like uh so there there are stories
where the teacher will say okay or
there's one viral right now where it's
like they she she put the uh the skin
color tabs on a chart
okay and then like had the kids line up
so that's like it i guess they're very
similar in a certain way but that's
overt right that's when like hey we're
going to take all the kids and line them
up by race whereas the secondary one is
like the math question implies some that
some critical race is real but they
don't it's surreptitious so there's like
i guess it's the subliminal and the
super liminal you know yelling at their
face when it comes to teaching the
theory i don't think it happens that
much yet like a nice 10th grade course
on the philosophy of critical race there
where you learn about from 1911 or 1920
when this began yeah you know and all
the things james lindsay talks about
with like the history of the theory
that'd be cool if they knew they were
learning it and they were interested in
studying it yeah as opposed to just
being told like whiteness is a thing and
yeah yeah when you're seven you know
yeah
i don't know the numbers though the the
classrooms don't have cameras in them
it's kind of disturbing that it's
happening in secret it is kind of crazy
to imagine there'd be cameras and
classrooms and all the kids are being
watched or whatever but body cams on
cops
that brings up another complication so
then we would have another uh freedom
liberty complication well so so what are
your thoughts on this you know uh
well i don't know about this case
specifically because it seems very vague
let's talk in terms of like you know
generalities okay should teachers
generality should teachers who implement
critical critical race theory or engage
in the practice should they be fired
well it's interesting because if if an
institution is being
inconsistent meaning if an institution
has decided to bring upon a policy where
they're teaching this to their staff and
they're saying
you know
this is
this is what is in vogue now and this is
what we're doing
and then let's say a new
culture cycle occurs and people
rail against it
and
from there teachers who are already in
in that institution who are say let's
say inculcated in critical race theory
uh continue to teach it
it's a bit
inconsistent for an institution to sort
of switch gears um
so i think it's obviously this probably
didn't happen in texas
with this particular teacher because
schools in texas i imagine aren't
teaching critical race theory so i don't
know about this particular case
but for other
schools and other states it might be
i think it might be
wrong to place the burden upon the
teacher if the institution brought this
to itself in the first place and then
switched gears
but isn't it is isn't there a deeper
problem i guess if parents
hate this stuff if you have like the
average person saying we don't want this
for our kids yeah how is it that a
school comes to be teaching this well
that's another that's a larger issue the
institution not actually
being in community with its parents and
really not even caring about what
parents have to say and the input of the
parents um and i think that probably
goes beyond critical race theory but and
it's probably been been an issue for a
long time um
so you're you have a startup that
teaches anti-racism yeah but define your
anti-racism because it's not the same as
like ebram kennedy's right no
so ibrahim kennedy defines
racism as basically the presence of
inequity so he defines inequity as
material outcomes between groups
so if there's a difference in outcomes
uh between different races then that's
proof of racial inequity and that's
proof of racism whereas our
understanding of racism is psychological
we understand that racism or supremacist
ways of thinking occur when an
individual or group of people experience
some kind of insecurity and then project
that insecurity onto others in order to
feel worthy and our our approach teaches
people how to practice dealing with
themselves in a holistic healthy way so
that they will be less likely to
overcompensate
interesting so what do you what so uh
what do you think about critical race
there i know you're not a big fan
what i mean i really don't think about
critical race theory i have to be honest
with you um and there are probably many
different reasons for that
you know as i said i've said this before
the show but i try not to be counter
dependent in my identity because that's
also a form of dependence
people tend to think that codependence
is the only form of dependence but
actually counter dependence is also a
form so counter dependence is when your
identity is dependent upon countering
someone else or something else
i you know i'm not a fan of critical
race theory because i'm not a fan of
post-modernism i think that there's no
transcendence at the heart of
post-modernism i think that
post-modernism has a point in that it
critiques
dominant
structures in society which are
susceptible to corruption just just by
nature of being
but the problem is that it becomes
parasitic and begins to eat itself and
so there's no actual transcendence at
the heart of it so i'm critical of
critical theory in general
um but i don't really think about credit
cory's theory uh because i'm just trying
to get our anti-racism program out there
if you avoid counter dependence how why
do you say you're anti-racist this is a
great question i love this question
because
we define racism not as a
another person or as a
analysis of outcome but as a state of
being
racism is a defect in
relational ways of being you're not
relating to yourself properly and you're
not relating to others properly and so
to be able to counter that presupposes
adopting a set of practices a kind of
lifestyle
um and i think in that sense it's less
parasitic because at the heart of it
where you're trying to reach is
transcendence
did you do like meditation and stuff
yeah
oh cool well how would you define racism
then
um again for me racism is a kind of
relational defect
um and it happens when a person is not
in the right relationship with
themselves so they're feeling a lack of
self-worth or contempt or
um but so like how does that present
itself in in society for instance right
so just just to clarify you have you
know iran kennedy's view about inequal
outcomes yeah you have the dictionary
definition of prejudice or
discrimination positively or negative on
the basis of race yeah i would say that
we're more of that of that uh latter
definition but we're also more
interested in psychological
underpinnings of what causes that
prejudice what drives that prejudice in
the first place
and where's that prejudice coming from
uh from again a deep psychological
perspective so like if a guy was walking
down the street in l.a and
kicked a a a piece of the sidewalk that
was up and busted his toe and was like
ah who's supposed to fix these sidewalks
and looks and it's like i bet it was
this race of people and looks and those
workers in the city tend to be
percentagely mostly a certain race yeah
and then they're like i knew it it's
that race like yeah what's that person
is not well with themselves and then
you'd have to go deep into their
individual psychology just like what
happened to you when you were a kid why
are you blaming people for kicking yeah
what's going on what's going on here
there's something going on there's
something else going on here
but so so here's my issue right with the
reason why i do
you know think critical race theory is
bad or i should say
critical race and i also think it's bad
by the way i'm just not
the reason i do focus on it is because i
think it's over at racism
yeah well but again that's that's what
we ultimately that's the beauty of it
that's what we ultimately tackle because
it doesn't matter whether you're black
or white you could be feeling some kind
of weird
self-worth issues and project and they
come out it can manifest in different
ways but that's ultimately what's at the
heart of it so in a way we're kind of
addressing critical reasons
yeah because when you think about these
young people and their animosity and the
things they they project
you know it's rooted in this
misunderstanding of what race is and
then a projected anger towards certain
races so when i when i when i look at
like critical race theory and applied
principles
i think they're they're overtly racist
they want they certainly against asian
people who are a small minority in this
country but yes also against white
people they they blame someone else but
many of many passionate critical race
theorists are white so what do you think
is going on with that
well uh
i think it's it's a lot of these people
it's tribal
so uh ibrahim kennedy for instance yeah
he's
his belief is basically that if there's
a law or policy that creates an eq an
equal outcome based on race it's a
racist systemically racist policy yet
when it comes to new york's vaccine
mandates which disproportionately impact
black people in new york he's nowhere to
be found yeah because his whole thing is
actually more
you know i'll put it this way
i would i would i would say i think he
believes a lot of what he says yeah but
i think he's i think so too i think he's
sitting there going yeah but i'm not
going to challenge this one instance
where it's happening because the people
who pay me also like that too
i i don't know but i'm but i'm what what
i'm wondering is i get all that but you
just said criticalis theorists are
tribal and they're like anti-white
people but a lot of the people who buy
into this are white so
so what's
what's going on there
they're tribalistically espousing an
ideology regardless of their own race
they're trying and in fact they say
things like as a white person i
recognize these things because they care
more about what their tribe says than
about who they are what they experience
and what the actual problem so what is
their tr who is their tribe who belongs
to their tribe there's so in the in the
culture war it's very strange but there
is very overarching tribe you know
tribal factions there's the left and the
right but that doesn't actually get to
the heart of what the factions are so
bill maher is considered to be kind of
in the left but he's kind of in the
middle of the culture war because he's
very anti-woke he's very critical of of
the booster shots
but he despises trump yeah and so he's
kind of in the middle on the right you
actually have liberals people who are
economically left sure it's it's it's
all scrambled
yes but it may actually just be
authoritarian versus libertarian in a
large way not completely not not
completely because you certainly have
people on the right who are
authoritarian
who are
you know yeah defying critical race
theory you know what i mean yeah yeah
but there's like a big component of it
is uh authoritarian versus libertarian
it may have a lot to do with
individualist versus collectivist but
again not absolute because there are
elements of the fringe far right ultra
you know
uh nationalists they're they're you know
collectivist in a certain to a certain
degree okay so it's it's
it really is hard to to figure it out
but i would say it's kind of like yin
yang you know what i mean it's not like
there's two equal spaces that are
opposing each other it's like they
actually swirl around and have you know
similarities and differences
when i when i look at uh like candy and
i look at um robin d'angelo but also
just the democratic party there's
something that's very you know very
obvious in that there is a substantive
lack of prince substantial lack of
principles and you know to i'll shout
out texas for instance for instance they
did the the the heartbeat bill okay and
all of a sudden we have people screaming
my body my choice okay yeah once again
i'll throw it back to new york i'm like
yo what about them mandating vaccines
because i'm pro-choice you know even
though i don't like abortion i think
it's bad and i agree with a lot of
conservatives on their on their
suppositions the the problem is the
government intervening for medical
reasons and it's like a very scary i
getting into nuance is difficult but i
look at texas and i'm like yeah i i
understand the exemptions i don't like
having to go to the government for a
medical you know something has to do
with a very serious embarrassing
humiliating or troubling medical
procedure
i'm gonna say the same thing about new
york city but all of a sudden now i see
this establishment and this like left
faction in the culture war
has no interest in defending bodily
autonomy or racist policy which is the
vex vaccine mandate new york city
so when it comes so throw it back to
what we were talking about the
overwhelming amount of white people who
are anti-white i think it's mostly
because they don't care about the ideas
if they did they my buddy my choice
would mean vax mandates too what they
care about is just being part of a
collective that vise for power it kind
of it makes me think of
self-flagellation like a religious
because we try to talk about a metaphor
like this sort of religion there's this
lack of religion in society so we've
kind of yeah some people have adopted a
new faith and yeah people would beat
themselves on the back with uh with
whips and stuff is part of like the
self-flagellation like i'm suffering i'm
so horrible original sin i'm a sinner
punished i must punish myself so that
i'm not punished in hell or whatever
yeah and i think these people kind of
have that same like self-punishment
mindset i don't know if this
self-flagellation is just part of the
human psyche that needs to be i think
there's agitated from time to time or
something i think there's a few
different things definitely it's like
working out you know a few different
things happening here some of these
people the less prominent you know white
uh people who are anti-white probably
don't actually care but they're scared
they want to fit in there are several
prominent activists who were always on
the left but the left as of today is
fundamentally different from the left of
10 years ago okay so uh my favorite
shout out is to rap news by juice media
they had a video 10 years ago if it was
in the end of 2010 where oh man it's
almost 11 years ago now where they say
you know hillary clinton is is bad alex
jones is calling out the kami nazi
fascists the the the uh
you know the the democrats and the
republicans the establishment are trying
to turn back the clock on freedom of
speech and all that stuff and i'm like
wow if you were to make that today you'd
be a trump supporter if you said hillary
clinton is bad and we had free speech
julian assange is good and alex jones is
speaking the truth
that was 10 years ago that was the left
yeah so there's been this very serious
shift a lot of people all of a sudden
are just like jay leno said it the other
day you know jalen story came out jay
leno said either you you get in line
with the woke or die
so that's you think that's true
no absolutely not okay i mean if you
want to be jay leno and be on tv yes
right we're we're lucky enough that
there exists an economic space where
this show can function but if the
internet didn't exist
this conversations would be happening in
secret but if the internet didn't exist
would any of this be would any of this
be happening probably not so right it's
a double-edged sword but but to be fair
something else would be happening right
you know before yeah war for instance
you know iraq war yeah lies in the media
so
it's
factions emerging
we avoided 1984 because we had the
internet the whole like never ending war
overseas where it's a different enemy
and then now you're fighting a different
enemy one day and all of a sudden 20
years later they're like and now we've
always been at war with your eastern you
know did you ever read 1984 yeah and so
we that would have been afghanistan and
iraq but since we had the internet we
saw it all oh we were like nope just
just to mention so the first group i
think are people who are scared i should
say the first group but there's a group
of people who are scared and they'll
just be like whatever you say leave me
out of it then you have true believers
who are just white people who are like
wow i can't believe this is what you
know
has really happened and i'm woke i've
awakened the world then you have
grifters i i genuinely think robin
d'angelo's a grifter like i think you
don't think she believes what she's
writing absolutely not okay why do you
why don't you think she believes it i
think fundamentally uh
her ideologies at least the way she
espouses it is absolutely contradictory
if so if you are a white person who
believes white people should step back
but plenty of people believe
contradictory things yeah i know yeah
genuinely and so that's a cognitive
dissonance where i challenge i will
challenge someone's uh
you know whether they actually believe
something and boy do people go nuts when
they when they realize it one example of
the difference between me and someone
like that is yeah i had been saying for
a while that look i think if a business
wants to mandate vaccines depending on
the scale of that business i think it's
actually fine because i don't want to
impose my will on a mom and pop shop
where it's like an older guy and he's
like look i'm hiring two or three people
i want them to vaccinate and i'm like i
don't want to infringe on the rights of
just a regular working-class dude yeah
then a week later i said it is the
people of new york who are upholding the
edict making this happen if the regular
people said no to the mandates all of
this would stop and then i said well
certainly both of those ideas can't be
true so perhaps it's wrong for
businesses to manage their employees get
the vaccine okay as opposed to what we
see with the you know my body my choice
people where they completely just say f
you i'm not going to argue about new
york it doesn't exist to me or they
won't even bring it but i don't think
that makes a person a grifter not to be
semantical
i just i
that doesn't make you a grifter i
suppose i suppose i can then say about
d'angelo is that based on
what i've heard from her and seen from
her i just believe she's lying okay like
i do not feel that what she says is
genuine i have no idea
so fair enough
yeah i mean it's all uh trying to
read people i guess yeah and
i think she had a heart hard childhood
yeah and i think that plays a huge role
elaborate well i read in passing
somewhere that she her father wasn't in
the picture abandoned the family she
grew up in going from like moving
constantly and also her mother was sort
of incompetent and she dealt with issues
of abandonment and identity issues at a
very young age and i am like i have
almost no doubt that that is playing a
huge role in in all of this
so it's possible she's just not that
smart
or and or it's possible that she is
spiritually suffering and this is how
it's manifesting high intelligence but
with a lot of pain that's a very
dangerous recipe too i don't think she
does
well so how do you how do you deal with
then you know how do you well you have
very prominent people very wealthy
people and big institutions that are
implementing the these these ideas at an
ever escalating rate of you know well
you i think i think one of the ways you
deal with it is you
you guard yourself as much as possible
from
from falling prey to
some of the
uh
shortcomings and
um i guess
blind spots and but you don't do that
simply by
propositional
exposition of facts who's right who's
wrong but you actually do it by
recognizing the complexity of the human
condition your capacity to fall prey to
that your capacity to
become susceptible to that way of
thinking and the pr and giving yourself
the practices required to not fall prey
to it because it's so easy to fall prey
to it in a in a way what are some of
those practices
meditation
for sure
shadow work from like carl young's
philosophy
shadow work is when you
you recognize what's triggering your ego
usually our egos are triggered by other
people
when they're doing something that we
don't like
that and that thing is present within us
now there's a difference between saying
to a person your behavior is reckless
your behavior is problematic and saying
to that same person who engaged in that
reckless behavior that you're trash
those are two very different things once
you start engaging in the latter kind of
vocabulary you set yourself up on a
pedestal and you set yourself up as
better than that person as if that
behavior is foreign to you as if you're
not capable of engaging in that same
behavior and you've actually started
down the path of supremacist ways of
thinking in the literal sense you think
that you're supreme you think that
you're superior to that person so you do
shadow work by you can do it in
many ways but one of the ways you can do
it is noticing when your ego is
triggered and recognizing how the
behavior that someone else engaged in or
the impulse that someone else is
operating out of is also existing within
you and you'll see that same behavior
the next time you'll still say it's
reckless and problematic but your ego
won't be triggered by it so you'll be
less likely to other that person when
you critique that person and then i
would imagine your criticisms will be
more likely to be taken by them exactly
they'll be able to receive it more
likely to receive it there's no
guarantee to anything but there's there
will be more likely to receive it sounds
like we just need to replace crt with
philosophy
yes self-reflection yeah is is i mean
that's that's our motto yeah yeah
so instead
i think what we end up getting is
too many people in the united states
don't want to be involved in any of this
yeah fighting is hard it's taxing and i
think you can look at the animal kingdom
fighting is never the first choice
so here's something here's something
interesting the the like the aggression
of an animal can be determined on where
it lives or where it operates so uh
burrowing animals for instance
when they're in when you encounter them
in a burrow they will fight you they're
aggressive they have one dimension to
move in they i so there's no escaping
birds don't attack you because birds can
just leave and leaving is way easier
so what ends up happening for regular
people is that
there are vested interests in spreading
crt and it's it's ideology there's money
to be made for sure
there are true believers
there are people who are scared of just
going along with it thinking they'll fit
in and then corporations say look this
is what's on social media we think this
plays well
i don't you know we don't want to rock
the boat and then it creates the social
pressure where over time people are just
like i don't want a fight so they give
in to the most aggressive ideology and
that leads us down a very very dark and
authoritarian path but then that thing
actually blows up in their faces and
then they come call us
no but i mean and many in many cases
they've they've brought in crt into the
staff into the training of their people
it wreaks havoc in the workplace do and
then they have to start all over again
do you have any specific examples like a
story you don't get to name the company
or anything like that but you want to
like give us an example
um
i mean i can just tell you in general we
do we do demo interviews with companies
all the time and they report back to us
it's a very like simple script that they
report back to us and it's repeated all
the time we brought in this very
typical
approach to diversity and inclusion
training and it did not go over well and
now we are trying to figure out what to
do and we heard you on some podcasts but
like how does that is the life cycle
like many cases just like what happened
specifically like like people were
self-segregated the diversity consultant
told them to segregate themselves based
upon race a lot of people don't like
that oh yeah that's standard that's
standard the consultant tells them or
just assumes the lived experiences of
all these people based upon skin color a
lot of people black and white don't like
that so i wouldn't underestimate the
amount of
rumblings that may be happening in these
companies even though they're not
necessarily you're not necessarily
seeing that on twitter but it's
definitely happening that makes me laugh
and it kind of makes me happy yeah the
like to hear that the things that we see
as bad for the reasons we see it as bad
are being reported back to you as that
they are bad and they don't work yes and
it's like it's like vindicating yeah but
it's also cool that you guys can come in
and kind of fix that yeah it tries you
so what would you what advice would you
like how do you work with a company that
contacts you
we so we have online courses but we also
have workshops ultimately we are a
startup and we're trying to get to the
place where we can
create a
suite of practices for organizations so
you know a one-time workshop and our
workshops are pretty dope i have to say
but it's like a full day workshop and
that doesn't translate into sustainable
practice it's just not the nature of a
workshop so what we want to ultimately
do is get our stuff into
as of training uh into the learning
management systems of corporations so
that when they're onboarding their
employees they can use our practices
eventually be able to
service them with some of our coaches
who can check in to make sure they're
doing those self-awareness practices
throughout the months weeks quarters etc
so ultimately we want people to start
practicing i mean the the emphasis is on
the practice i had a conversation
recently uh with someone who was talking
about policy and they were like we wrote
a statement because this is also very
popular as i'm sure you know like let's
make a statement about how we are
super anti-racist and
and i'm like that's not a policy that's
a statement a policy is a set of
practices that an institution operates
according to so we can have a long-term
conversation about what those practices
should look like again with the
with the objective of affording that
sense of
self-awareness
not overcompensating for your
insecurities creating a culture of
belonging we can actually talk about how
to create those practices but what you
have this is not a policy it's just a
statement
i remember that famous george carlin
sketch where he just goes on stage and
says every single racial slur he can
think of and then he actually calls
eddie murphy and richard pryor the n
word which like before my time yeah i
mean i think it was like early 90s how
old are you i'm 28. oh okay so
maybe
i was probably too young to watch two
years old but it might have been like
94. i was one years old right exactly
but uh
you know even even when i see that i'm
like wow i can't believe he would even
jokingly say that about these guys yeah
but everyone in the crowd laughs yeah
there was no big controversy over him
doing it because the point he was making
when he said it was that
you need to understand the person behind
the words because the words themselves
don't affect you sticks and stones et
cetera so i i mean because i wonder in a
lot of these corporate settings someone
might say an off caller joke you know
without the intent to actually
demean someone yeah but then someone
might get offended by triggering these
sessions yeah someone well i don't i
don't think that's what's triggering
primarily you don't think so no like
we've heard stories about people who are
like oh i said a joke at work and now
they're making me go to like a diversity
training i think that's a lot i think
that like companies are conservative and
they're like oh we don't want you to sue
us
so that's why they're doing that i don't
think it's like driven by any real thing
no i i completely agree with you i just
i just mean like oh someone said a
naughty word we might get sued quick put
them in a diversity training to protect
ourselves yeah but i don't think i agree
but unfortunately or fortunately
whatever the end of critical race theory
doesn't solve for that problem because
the institutions will always be like
that right
not to mention crt segregates people
which i think makes that worse yeah well
it does make it worse yeah oh good good
little fact objectively george carlin
did that seven words you can never say
on tv in 1972. oh so i definitely was
not born no no no no no
i'm not i'm not talking about that's the
first album oh you're talking about
something i'm talking about in the early
90s george carlin has a routine where he
says he says like a hundred racial
slaves he repeated this act over and
over through the years and it i think he
developed it the the bit he did on
racism was
the word doesn't matter it's the racist
a-hole behind the word you got to watch
out for
because he's like i can say and then he
says you might be a and then he just
starts saying racial slavery just like
that might be dirty words he's done a
bunch of this kind of stuff it's not the
seven words you can't say it is a bit
from the early 90s and then he ends by
calling richard pryor eddie murphy the n
word and i'm like wow like but so i
bring this up too because i'm i'm just
curious as to
the way uh
i'm i have people who make asian jokes
you know at me throughout my whole life
and i think they're hilarious yeah i
mean because i know my friends are just
like ribbon on me
or uh the you know they're just
making fun of the stereotypes and the
absurdity and it doesn't affect me
because i'm secure in who i am and i'm
just like oh that's a funny funny thing
like if there's a stereotype about asian
people and then i end up doing something
and then people point it out i'll be
like ah geez you know it's like it's fun
i'm not i'm only a quarter korean uh
part japanese and korean but i'm curious
as to like what would your approach be
in circumstances where someone might be
like someone made a racist joke i'm
upset about it i don't know
honestly that's my honest question i
really depends on the context and
situational details
um i do think it's interesting that they
just took down the first episode of the
office
which is it was the first episode i
think so no fact check me on that okay
uh the old ones yeah yeah which i saw
coming i saw it coming and it was i
unfortunately no one asked for this but
um here we are here we are
so is it the first one
i'm i'm not pulling up snopes on this no
way
all right so here we have it from metro
office the uh the office u.s fans
furious as comedy central removes
diversity day episode from schedule are
you a big fan of the office yeah
especially that episode especially the
episode that is one of the most
brilliant episodes of the office so they
say diversity day is the second
installment of the first season second
installment of the office u.s and
follows michael as he forces the staff
at dunder mifflin to undergo a racial
diversity seminar a consultant larry
wilmore arrives to each staff about
tolerance and diversity but michael
insists on imparting his own knowledge
aggravating both the consultant and the
entire office staff and creates his own
diversity seminar he eventually assigns
each staff member in an index card with
a different race on it causing tempers
to slowly simmer until they finally snap
so what do they say comedy central
is removing diversity episode from the
rotation is so corporate and stupid
why why was it removed though they said
they say it was taken down
they don't really explain exactly why it
was taken down or was their official
statement or anything just as video
unavailable
wow
did you did you hear like why it was
removed or what the reason was they say
from time to time they'll they'll not
play certain episodes in rotation from
time to time i mean i it doesn't take a
brain surgery to figure out why this is
listen maybe maybe there's something we
don't know we can give them the benefit
of the doubt but i
i suspect it is the reason that we think
it is
that is a funny episode it's such a
great episode because no no it's tough
to say because like when it comes to
comedy if you're making someone the butt
of the joke that in general is kind of
kind of hard for me to swallow i get i
get kind of like why would you hurt that
michael scott that's the po michael
scott is a ridiculous human being that's
the whole point you see an idiot making
mistakes yeah that's the point of that
and you you also learn to love you you
learn to to fall in love with that idiot
that's the whole point if you take see
this is why i ultimately think so so
much that's happening with regards to
critical race theory uh broadly speaking
is going to lead to the death not well
hopefully not the death but
a suppression of art and the arts and
absolutely we at theory of enchantment
use the arts to teach everything so like
if you if you enroll in our online
course
we use
uh philosophy and music and
poetry and
film to actually teach people our three
main principles because we know that the
purpose of the arts is to remind people
of the complexity of the human
experience as opposed to my opinion
politics these days which reduces and
stereotypes and caricatures human beings
to one label or the other the entire
purpose of the arts is to be expansive
and so i'm not surprised if in fact this
is the reason why that happened with the
office
i'm not surprised because that is the
inevitable
that's the logical conclusion and what's
ultimately
ironic about this is that that means
that a lot of things that are coming out
of critical race theory or critical race
theory light or whatever you want to
call it are ultimately antithetical to
the african-american ethos and that is
one of the greatest
scandals that no one is talking about
what do you mean the act for a american
ethos what is that like so there's a
great author albert murray who wrote
this book the omni-americans or
alternatives to the folklore of white
supremacy he wrote it in like the 70s or
something like that he was this really
dope jazz critic
and he talked about how within
african-american culture
there is
what he calls a kind of idiomatic
expression which he defines as impromptu
heroism culture another synonym of this
is the hero's journey so if you're
familiar with like joseph campbell or
carl jung and that sort of thing and he
talks about how in jazz as an art form
and in
the blues there's this
philosophy that affords musicians the
ability not only to literally play with
music but metaphorically play with
anything that life brings them both the
both the negative potential and the
positive potential and that is a part of
the artistic art form that is central to
african-american culture and so once you
start
once you start going down the path of
the death of metaphor the death of
context
and all of these things you're talking
about the death of art and you're
talking about something the death of
something very central to african
american life i love this about jazz is
because you'll start on a note you're in
a key and you'll hit all the wrong notes
that aren't in the right key yeah then
you'll you'll end on the right note in
the key and that's like the hero's
journey all the mistakes along the way
and then you're which are necessary
which are necessary there's this uh
recording i was listening to recently of
norm mcdonald okay he was on a radio
show apparently with like a woke pot
like producer or radio host or maybe
she's just one of those people who's
like i'm just going to say what i'm
supposed to say cuz i'm on the radar
canceled and nor macdonald have you ever
listened to this guy
i don't think so i mean i know of him
but i know he i don't think i've heard
him definitely he's got this thing where
he talks in a very like slow and blunt
way and that's how he drives his comedy
so he's talking and he goes
you two might get mad at me but i'm
quoting norma mcdonald
oh no is this one of these no no no he
says
he says black people are poorer than
white people and poor people are
dangerous and he was just he was quoting
information right that's what he says
and then the host goes no oh whoa whoa
you can't say that no no and he was like
what do you mean and she's like you you
can't say that about black people and he
goes you think black people are richer
than white people
no no i'm not saying that and he goes
poor people commit crimes that's what
they keep saying isn't it he's like i
don't think i think systemic racism is a
real thing and that means you and and so
the way he said it yeah shocked and
offended people they started getting
calls and people were calling in like
you can't say that you know i went to
school with two black people and they
were they were way richer than i was and
then he goes yeah and a guy in a
wheelchair could probably be faster than
me but if i said i'm typically faster
than people in wheelchairs i'd be
telling you the truth yeah and so what
was really what i found really
fascinating about
what he said when he said that is we
often hear from the critical race
theorists things like
systemic racism is a real problem which
creates generational wealth gaps which
results in a disproportionate amount of
black people being impoverished relative
to white people
however there are more white people who
are impoverished then they say poverty
breeds crime and
actually i'm my understanding is it's
all true right your crime isn't based on
race it's based on
poverty levels circumstances but when
nor mcdonald just says it that way yeah
it actually made them argue against him
because the way he said it was so blunt
it came off as kind of offensive or
racist you know what i mean yeah yeah i
don't know i i was curious about it when
uh you had mentioned something before
before i got the jazz thing came and
kind of threw me off track that's what
jazz does that's right that's right
you'll be back though
in talking about like
um
you're making a comment about diversity
trainings and like critical race theory
and it's like removing
art the arts fundamentally that is my
biggest issue
with it i guess the reason i want to
bring this mcdonald's thing is that i
think it shows
the
there's something about the way you say
things
it's less to do with what the idea is
for a lot of these people who are
claiming to be like anti-racist or
whatever that the way nor mcdonald could
come out and say this but defended
people
so you think if he would have said it
differently it wouldn't have offended
people
absolutely i think if norma mcdonald
said you know one of the challenges we
face is systemic racism which has
resulted in a disproportionate amount of
the black community being impoverished
and then you find that racists blame
them when the poverty leads to crime and
people say oh yes i agree with that
that's very very intelligent but when
norm mcdonald the regular guy is like
says what he said they're like whoa whoa
you can't say that and all of a sudden
like their own idea brought back to them
like in from a mirror of a regular guy
is all of a sudden now but in a
different form
and just is he intentionally offensive
does he aim does he try to offend people
well yes but in this capacity i think
it's just who he is okay it's like he's
he's the kind of guy who's just gonna
whittle it down very basically and then
he had he was kind of shocked that they
were like
you can't say that no he was like what
do you mean he's like
we say it all the time like what yeah
that's interesting that's art i mean
they say often i've heard that people
when they think back they remember how
you made them feel they don't
necessarily remember what you said
exactly yeah there's another george
carlin a bit where he talks about the
changing of language he says he's he
said we used to we used to say
that when people go to war they would
come back with i think i remember this i
think i've seen this one and then he's
like now we say post-traumatic stress
disorder
and that's interesting because
the the way you say something could be
offensive to someone regardless of the
idea you're trying to convey
for sure it also depends upon that
person's state of mind which is why it's
complicated so put to put all the
illness on the person who is presumably
giving offense it could be that a person
is actually
empty inside and so because they're
empty inside they will take everything
to offense because they have low
self-esteem i think we see that very uh
prominently among the
woke
the the establishment left they're i
think they're very insecure
okay and that's why they tend to be more
collectivist and that's why they tend to
be more more like do you think more
insecure people are collectivists what's
the relationship between collectivism
and insecurity finding validation from
someone else instead of themselves well
but let me ask you this question don't
you think there's a
hyper-individualistic
problem within america and or do you
think that so i'm trying to see what the
balance is between
like hyper atomization of the individual
and
uh collectivism so i would say um
they're they're probably i think there
is a problem with individuals in the
united states yeah and it and it it
forms itself in that nobody's willing to
stand up for a common set of values
they're like look i can't lose my job
i'm not going to speak up
and that results in you know kind of
chaos okay if you if you have
you know an element of what we refer to
as the left in the culture war that are
absolutely willing to just say whatever
the tribe says even if the you know
the change of the wind or whatever like
one day they're making fun of asian
people yeah yeah and they started
cancelling their own activists because a
year ago it was okay to hate a nation
people and call them white adjacent
right and so for for them
their willingness to stand up and speak
up and yell no matter what because they
seek validation from others results in
them gaining territory
in institutions i guess what i'm
wondering is though uh reinhold niebuhr
has this wonderful quote in one of his
essays i forgot the name of it um
everyone should read reinhold neighbor
though yes he's awesome um where he says
man needs liberty but also a man needs
community and there will always be a
tension between those two so i'm just
wondering what where does community and
and collectivism begin for you um
collectivism in my critique is more
about
disregarding fundamental principles and
values for the sake of just fitting in
okay finding your value in someone else
because you don't find any within
yourself okay so i think
i i would say something like hey here
are the things that i believe in i
believe there's you know intrinsic
rights that human beings have no matter
what even if you try to take them away
and i think we should protect those
rights but i also recognize at a certain
point we have to have common missions
one of the big problems with the united
states is actually
the right has lost their sense of
collective in a lot of ways
and the left has lost their sense of
principle
you know so now it's just like
people on the right don't protest
they've started to more so in recent
times but it's still typically the same
groups and not the average person who
finds themselves on the right as it were
okay the left protests for anything even
if it makes no sense like when antifa
comes out and says we're against fascism
but then actually beats people in
defense of state mandates which is like
what sure because they'll come out for
anything yeah so
i don't know i think
obviously one of the greatest the
greatest times in american history like
the space race going to the moon yeah we
had a national mission
we all came together we all believed in
it and now we have lost social cohesion
the left has some kind of weird social
cohesion but it's not rooted in i don't
know about that i mean
you know the way
maybe maybe that's fair maybe it's fair
but they are connected somehow you know
what i mean like they follow they follow
it's it's it's a it's a swarm of bats
i think much of it is superficial
i think a lot of it is super i don't
think it's like
i think you like strike the shepherd and
the sheeple scatter sort of thing
on the on the left yeah i don't know
i went to a black lives matter protest
last year in brooklyn
and i held up a sign from that had a
kendrick lamar quote that's around it a
fatal attraction is common and while we
have communist pain to try to spark a
conversation about how in many cases the
same
uh
fears traumas what have you that
communities are experiencing also exist
within the police officers that are
policing those communities so but that
didn't actually spark any conversation
but what i did notice was that there was
no actual spiritual underpinning
uh
people knew what they
didn't want they didn't know what they
wanted
and um and so
that
was not i mean yes i i met people who
have become my friends for sure but that
was not for example in comparison to the
civil rights movement it's something
that created actual sustainable
community so i'm i'm curious
i would question the stability and
sustainability of
some of the movements today i question
whether or not they actually know what
they don't want
well that's fair so one of one one of
the things that uh i talk about a bit is
they claim to know what they don't want
i don't say that right when they claim
sometimes claim to know what the
solutions are abolish the police or
defund the police but they clearly don't
want that because then when the police
show up and arrest their political
opponents they cheer for it sure one of
the things i think we see uh
that i bring up often the root of the
culture war in my opinion or one of them
was how algorithms were feeding people
shock content for money
and so what happened is you're let's say
you're 10 years old in in 20 in 2009
and you get on facebook even though
they're not supposed to because it's you
know for 13 year olds and up but you
know kids are on it anyway yeah all of a
sudden you see in your facebook feed a
police brutality video a black man being
beaten by a cop okay
there were there were websites that were
making millions of dollars posting
nothing but police brutality videos
because it's shocking and it gets clicks
outrage yeah so now you're 10 you see
these videos and it's all and you click
on it so facebook says let's give you
more
then 10 years later these videos have
become dominant because it made so much
money for people that now there's a
there's a there's someone who's voting
who genuinely believes
the world is nothing but police hunting
down black people
their whole world view is built upon
this fictional reality of these extreme
instances that are actually exceedingly
rare they're bad and we should stop them
no doubt yeah but exceedingly rare then
they show up at a protest and quite
literally verbatim they say police are
hunting us down yeah and if you try and
tell them like hey
that's not true
they get angry they get violent
and then how do you calm someone down
whose whole life has been built into
this broken world view well that's not
the space first of all to try and
console someone down for sure but i
don't mean like go to a protest and walk
up to somebody who's angry and screaming
and say hey you're wrong i mean like
even even my friends
where it's like i've been i was hanging
out their house and i would say things
like this they'd be like you're wrong
you don't understand and i can't believe
you would say this stuff like i did i
thought you i can't believe you're a
racist and i'm like dude why are you
getting angry you know i mean i'm not
mad i'm just these things are reality
well i think it's
i don't know you might be having a
overly cerebral response to an emotional
express uh form of expression that is
correct uh and i don't think you will
that doesn't match
those two will never match you need an
emotional expression to respond to an
emotional expression but here's the
right balance of cerebral and emotional
here's the challenge i face with this uh
so when i used to do uh non-profit
fundraising canvassing stuff like that
okay uh
oh hands down i knew absolutely the
emotional pitch was always better than
the factual pitch
when i was working for a homeless
shelter i didn't go up to people and say
did you know that 17 children per day
are found blah blah blah and if we work
together the average annual budget of
the homeless shelter will come nobody
cares but if i said yo
we had a kid last night
his parents both died in a fire and now
he's sleeping in the ditch
i want you to i want you to think about
that for two seconds like what is that
could you imagine not having parents and
then they'd be like oh my geez like what
do i got to do the emotional was always
better but you know what
i don't like it because it's
because it's disingenuous why is it
disingenuous so
when when you're honest with someone
you
can be nice to them you can be
compassionate empathize and say
i am going to lead you to water and i'm
going to be nice about it
but if you've got someone who's like
fervently locked in a world view over a
decade of believing that cops are
hunting down black people
and you try to say to them
you know listen i understand these
things are horrible i would like to help
you in stopping them from happening i
would also like to consider that
we you know these these instances
are exceedingly rare and though we
definitely should focus on fighting them
we should try to do it from a
level-headed perspective and they'd be
like no you're wrong you're not you're
wrong i see the videos all the time i go
on reddit it's nothing but these videos
you're trying to you're trying to
downplay
but why should your reaction be
dependent upon theirs
meaning just because they're lo may be
lost in a world view
you're not
you're not changing your reaction or
because they're going to be stuck or
paralyzed you're changing your reaction
or you're responding in a way that's
empathetic because you believe in
empathy you're responding in a way
that's compassionate because you believe
in compassion not because
you say oh well compassion didn't work
so i'm just gonna throw it throw it all
out throw my hands up imagine trying to
tell someone two plus two equals five
i don't think that's a good comparison
telling some i think you're comparing
like a mathematic equation to like
things that fundamentally involve human
beings and which which goes beyond the
abstraction i'm not talking about the
equation i'm talking about the reaction
people would have to being told
something that they hold is
fundamentally true and you're
contradicting it okay fair enough so i
think if you look at a person like daryl
davis the guy who successfully got
dozens of members of the kkk to leave
the kkk right by going to their rallies
and being literally in community with
them
his approach was not simply to go up to
them and say let me tell you why you're
wrong
his approach was to genuinely deeply
listen to them and to hold space for
them for the purpose of holding space
for them not for this is this is tricky
not for the purpose of convincing
convincing them that they were wrong
they just so happened to be convinced
that they were wrong by the mere
presence continuous presence but but he
wasn't simply spewing faxes and he was
choosing to be in community with him and
that's not a surrea or a purely cerebral
fact-based approach you are correct
that's true yeah yeah well we we i did
an event uh with some friends we had
daryl davis speak and you're absolutely
correct on that um there were instances
where he did challenge them though
because being their friend he would
right you could challenge them you know
at a certain point the challenge is no
longer a threat to your identity that's
but
to pave that road first i think you're
absolutely right i think we should
just try to have more friends who we
disagree with and just invite them into
our spaces it is difficult it's
extremely difficult but again this is
the key
this is the hard part
not inviting them in order to persuade
them to change their mind no just invite
people to be friends to just in the
spirit of fellowship
yeah
you know the challenges though um
i think when you look at someone like
daryl davis there's there's a there's a
certain kind of like realization about
who those people were who are nasty and
racist because not all of them were
converted a lot of them were converted
and the people were converted were the
people who weren't necessarily true
believers but they were in a community
and they just held things to be true
because that's all they ever heard
many of the guys that daryl davis met
with never even met a black person
before sure and so when they were like
oh i know about this but they weren't
like evil yeah so they were like by all
means you can i believe in freedom and
you can talk and say what you want but i
hold these views and then they realize a
lot of those things weren't true just by
talking to them
one of the challenges is there's an extr
when it comes to like the wokeness and
the culture war
you can't even get through to these
people let me tell you something when we
we did this event in uh it was in it was
in i can't remember the name of the town
so i lived in i used to live in south
jersey okay and we there was this little
theater
just it's about an hour outside of
philadelphia
at the very last minute
self-proclaimed anti-fascists threatened
to burn the theater down
because we were holding an event called
ending
was ending racism violence and
authoritarianism
we had an array of speakers libertarians
conservative we had no identitarian
speakers i mean either left actually no
we had some progressive you know crt
activists we invited them but we didn't
invite any right or white identitarian
types okay
daryl davis was the
headline speaker huge fans yeah it's an
amazing story
and they threatened to bring the the
theater down within a we had booked the
thing almost a year in advance
the uh the manager was like don't worry
we've had ann coulter here before we can
deal with protests
he couldn't deal with the violence
so he terminated our contract and said
we will not welcome you and if you come
you will we'll call the police to have
you arrested and so he was like sue me
and there's nothing we can really do
yeah we moved the main event to a casino
okay on the other side of the river
which cut our capacity in half and did
cause us financial damage people weren't
able to buy tickets yeah but we had the
event we had daryl davis
however a very brave uh
couple or i'm sorry sorry they they
divorced a very brave men and women who
uh had a bar across the street refused
to cancel the after party in the face of
threats and of violence and protest
and we told them like we are here for
you we got your back we you know don't
worry we will take care of you no matter
what happens like we're in this together
and they said we're having the after
party no one's gonna bully us
we know who you are we know who daryl
davis is we're we're we're proud we
agree and this is insane
antifa and see our like you know woke
activists black lives matter showed up
and daryl davis
this is the craziest thing
um a black man who walked into clan
rallies shook the hands with white
supremacists and converted them
walked across the street to antifa and
they all started screaming nazi at him
and he they wouldn't let him speak
he ended up posting on facebook a very
viral post where he said i am shocked in
all of my efforts meeting with white
supremacists as a black man they have at
least given me the chance to speak to
have the conversation to become friends
but by simply walking across the street
they won't even let them talk at all
the mob is not an individual we're going
back to this individual versus
collective collectivism but crazy when a
mob i guess i guess what i'm trying to
emphasize here is there's something
fundamentally different about what's
going on now versus i disagree i mean
i i i know i knew that that is what you
were saying
but
i mean
i feel it's
necessary that i remind people of the
civil rights movement and of the
uh
and of the
of the circumstances of the civil rights
movement i mean churches were being
bombed and
ruby bridges had to walk to school where
white people were yelling
racial slurs and coming to her with
literally
uh ropes around a black doll's neck to
tell her that they wanted to hang her
and schools were being threatened with
all of the very similarly and so i
disagree with this notion that
woke fervor is somehow
radically different from say
the
uh things that were happening during
segregation in the jim crow south i mean
i think it's
it's just not objectively true
and you know you brought this point up
earlier about history i think we tend to
forget how intense that was
and
equally intense and philosophically
undergirded the response to it and it
needed to be because of the intensity of
the circumstances that many of the civil
rights leaders found themselves in but
it was absolutely similar if not worse
to everything you're describing but in
this in this story where you know you
referenced daryl davis and his ability
to go
but the clan is in disarray and sure
it's in a weakened state they have no
strong tenants and so it's very strong
so the stronger argument is the civil
rights movement but then you mentioned
this this young woman who had all these
white people screaming at her do you
think she could have walked up to one of
them and shook their hand and said we
don't have a conversation i don't i
don't think that the proper
uh thing to do
strategically is to try to go shake like
when people were
protesting segregation in the jim crow
south they weren't going up to white
supremacists to try to shake their hands
no i mean like if you went to a white
rally like a clan rally and they were
saying don't allow no because i'm saying
that at that time at that time the
circumstances were similar to what
you're describing with antifa that's
what i'm saying and yeah i agree yes but
you said it's very hard to pursu you
said it's very hard to persuade these
kinds of people but i'm saying the civil
rights movement the philosophy of the
civil rights movement understood that
what was at bottom fundamentally of what
these people what these racist people
were doing
was a
lack
that a vapid lack internally that they
were projecting onto the other and so
the entire
point of the non-violent movement
stemmed from this understanding that
even as i protest you
i know that you were my brother and that
you are my sister and i'm not going to
do you harm that is and that
that moved the culture fundamentally um
not only because of the visuals of that
but because again the philosophy was
deeply spiritually rooted and so i'm
saying that is precisely the kind of
response that is required in these days
and times we we've uh uh some we've had
a few leftists on this show and it's
very difficult
for a few reasons yeah it's not just
about fundamental disagreements yeah
some people just want to exploit the
show
and potentially cause it harm and we
watch out for that so like we might
book someone will come on and then
starts breaking all the rules on purpose
and trying to get us banned oh uh and i
think um that's wild oh yeah yeah we
have yeah there are people who've tried
to exploit the show and we're like i
know their game we're not gonna you know
yeah uh because they they don't like us
and i think the other is there's a fear
of
i guess
excommunication cancel culture okay so
there have been instances where people
are like look i'd love to come on the
show but i just can't deal with that
kind of heat
and other people have dealt with this
too very prominent uh figures on youtube
in the culture war have their guests get
harassed relentlessly for coming on and
it scares them away and say i can't do
this
but we have had a few different leftists
on the show who've been willing to come
on and we are absolutely uh i thought
they went very very well yeah i don't
know if we can say we're you know we're
friends because i wouldn't want i
wouldn't impose that on them but i
thought we got along swimmingly yeah and
we've had vosh friends on the show a
couple times and uh ian's a big fan i
love him wait are you talking he's a big
fan of me his name's ian awesome you're
both fans yeah he's a big fan of ian
yeah and so i actually i've i've really
enjoyed uh having you know vosh you know
coming on he's a socialist he's
very left he was pro-biden you know a
lot of things we disagree with um he's
he's i i think it's fair to say he's pro
crt and all this stuff okay and you know
what happens is after the show we're
talking d and video games
and that's always what happens yeah yeah
exactly it's like hey you know like
we're we are not uh i i like you you
might notice we have this poster here uh
back there shout out to brent l'engle of
snow white zombie apocalypse
so we argue on facebook all the time and
he's a lefty guy and and i'm like kind
of but i'm not authoritarian i'm very
libertarian so like policy comes second
to freedom to me and uh
you know he put up a kickstarter for
this and i was like i thought it looked
really cool yeah i was like i liked the
art i thought it was fantastic so i was
like i'll i'll pitch it for this
kickstarter and i posted about it saying
look me and this guy we argue all the
time but i have no no animosity or hard
feelings towards i actually enjoy you
know having these discussions and and
it's never uh i think in this instance
we're not screaming at each other and
insulting each other because we're good
people yeah and there are bad people on
twitter who just want to say nasty words
yeah but my point was like if we focused
on the things that we had more in common
maybe we'd actually better understand
each other things we don't have in
common absolutely or actually just learn
how we can live together to get through
these certain things but i got to tell
you it's really really challenging with
a mainstream media apparatus that would
say something like joe rogan took horse
medicine
that kind of stuff um the example i
always use sorry audience for beating a
dead horse
no pun intended democrats believe the
economy is good mm-hmm
independent voters and republicans
believe the economy is not good mm-hmm
oh i saw you posted this it is yeah it
is objectively true the economy is not
good
um i suppose there's some metrics where
you could like isolate one specific
thing like well the unemployment rate
went down by 0.2 percent yes but that
doesn't make a good economy when you
have
500 000 below expectation jobs how is it
that democratic voters think the economy
is good right now i mean new york
businesses are losing money because of
the mandates
they're speaking about they're
complaining about it major shortages
price increases
it's just bad i mean we had record job
openings 10.1 million last month and
then we only filled 235 000 they
expected 800 or whatever like we still
have a massive we have mass resignations
people are quitting their jobs
but people live in the matrix
you know what i mean so that what makes
it really really difficult is
when you try and even invite someone to
come on
and they're like i'm not gonna go on a
nazi show or something because the media
said bad words yeah you know what i mean
yeah i mean you gotta take it all in
stride
but how do you how would you navi like
so i i agree with you in a lot of what
you said you know about you know like
meeting people as just a person
not for the sake of winning or
persuading but how do you how do you
navigate people who are constantly
inundated by lies and deception to keep
them away from you
you understand that you are not and
cannot be omnipotent and you cannot
control everything and you accept
the good and the bad and you roll with
the punches
but what if you're trying to what if
you're trying to make sure and you're
like i mean look it's i i suppose i
i agree
but it might be a bit pessimistic like
as if to say that i'm watching a
building fall down knowing there's
nothing i can do to stop it see that's
very interesting because i i do think
that i'm pretty optimistic
and
i know there are no guarantees with
anything
but i do believe in culture i actually
believe in culture these days far more
than i believe in politics and i think
that the culture is actually far more
robust
uh
and gives us the space to have
conversations with people which with
whom we disagree and
um and i think that maybe if you
in addition to you know meeting people
in order to get to know them and things
like that leaned into the culture more
than the politics i would be curious
where that would get you
in terms of how you perceive others and
how others perceive you i agree you know
so we we have the cass castle vlog which
is like it's the next it's the latest
show that we launched we've got a couple
of the show other shows we're launching
one's going back mysteries we've done
uh we've done like recordings of it and
we're doing music and editing and stuff
could be fun yeah and the reason we
started doing the vlog there's two big
reasons one is like man the new stuff we
do is so negative all the time yeah like
ian points it out it's like all we do is
highlight this bad stuff and i'm like we
gotta hide like fun good stuff yeah and
so the vlog is like we have baby
chickens look how cute they are they're
growing up they're getting big and now
they're looking goofy because they're in
that puberty stage where they have some
feathers but not looking i look really
weird yeah and so the goal of the vlog
is just to be like fun and inspirational
for sure building culture that's dope
and i i one of the complaints i have
about the republicans because i you know
i i think i think we used to have a unit
party the democrats republicans are like
the same thing yeah then the you know
the right-wing populist kind of busted
in the republican party but the
republicans still very much think the
path towards victory is like appointing
judges yeah
i think trump supporters understand
that's not the case it's the cultural
institutions
that's going to shape the future okay
and what where
what are the cultural institutions the
apprentice
that was one of them the office
the office so tv shows oh absolutely for
example tv film and yeah
colleges colleges
media yeah
yeah
i was uh man i've been watching reruns
of 30 rock you ever watched i literally
just started restarted watching 30 rock
that is that is uncanny
maybe maybe netflix just like
recommended 30 rock because i was
thinking about it for some reason it's
the first show i watched when i moved to
new york um and so yeah i love that show
and it's a show that couldn't be made
today yes and that's the issue you know
what really
was like a knife in the heart
was when i'm watching i think it's like
the third episode and tina fey i don't
know it's like i don't know what episode
it is but um jenna
is doing a photo shoot for maxim yeah
and there's like loud noise and a fan or
whatever and the guy interviewing her
asks her about the war and she says
something but you can't hear it and he
writes down i hate the troops
and so there's this big thing in a
magazine saying that she hates the
troops and tina fey is like or you know
liz lemon why did you say that she was i
didn't say that he misheard me in those
protests
she says
okay you know jack donaghy goes we're
putting you on hardball with tucker
carlson and chris matthews to debate
this so good and then liz says something
like
just say the war was started under false
pretenses and it was horribly planned
and that you respect the troops and
don't blame them for this and i was just
like man where did that rhetoric go
where where was that left obama he came
in saying he was going to fix it and
then didn't and a lot of it got left the
baggage got left in his garage i will
just add to finish the joke because it
was amazing
she calls tucker carlson very attractive
which is fun
because they would never allow that yeah
they would never allow tucker carlson to
appear and be called attractive he was
on msnbc and she says something that's
really funny because it's 2007 she said
i think the government needs to hunt
down obama and that's why i'm voting for
osama in 2008
and that's 30 rock you couldn't you
couldn't get away with any of that such
a good show
but the reason why i'm optimistic is
because it's starting to eat like
so much of the art that we love and i
think that artists like will revolt
against them we have to now because if
it gets eaten and it's gone they won't
know that it existed in the first place
and then they won't be able to so we
gotta do it but the artists are still a
lot like steve carell is still alive you
know like yeah but like i mean i
understand jay leno has always been like
an awful shill but he said get woke or
die
let's see i don't know why i wouldn't
expect him to say that no he would be
the last comedian i'd expect to say look
at rage against the machine
i don't follow them but you understand i
don't know anything
about what they said recently they have
a lyric in a song f you i won't do what
you tell me yeah now they've become the
band of f you better do what they tell
you
um
well i think that's because we're moving
through a liminal i just want to i just
want to give context because i think it
helps us to empathize with people
uh we're going through an incredibly
liminal phase stage right now
with the pandemic and
everything on top of the pandemic
whether it's
uh you know
race relations polarization
constant
outrage
from social media
we're going through a liminal
stage where people's rituals have been
upended
where people have
lost their sense of being connected and
and things like that and so we're
dealing with an incredible amount of
emotional scarcity and in a time of
emotional scarcity people become
extremists it's like a law of human
nature and so on some level what's
happening is like
horrible but on another level it's also
expected
uh from a like a 10 000 foot level and
so the question for me is more how
how can we
how can we adopt sorry to keep uh
reiterating this word how can we adopt
certain practices certain relational
ways of being so that we can deal with
this very difficult time and i think a
lot of what you're seeing is ultimately
a a
misdirected or misapplied
flailing for air in response to
many crises whether that's identity
crises uh you know pandemic related
crises all of the above yes i agree and
i think that's why you'll see
there's protests over masks there's
protest over gender there's protests
over race and it seems like the culture
war is a million things at once and
and one thing like there's a left and a
right and they're fighting each other
but then you hear people like oh parents
are protesting which which reason is
that they're protesting now
why does the left have these tenants
that are you know i mean it's like it
seems like there's a bigger overarching
yeah it's a emotional vacancy i thought
that was pretty insightful that you said
that yeah like the scarcity there's a
scarcity and and so one thing i'll do is
when i'm fasting um i start to get more
in touch with my emotions i'll cry more
or if i take psilocybin i'll cry more
like i get more real and then i'm able
to feel other people yeah you know we
should have something this obesity
thing's terrifying man it's hard to feel
when you're stuffed with food i just i
just i just have an idea that's true i
think we can solve the problem
we need a monk
a shaman
and a priest or to walk into a bar yeah
to walk into a school grind bar maybe
walk into a school yeah and have a
serious conversation with a bunch of
young students
just about the great questions of life
yes
everything that's going on
fundamentally has to do with the great
questions of life and and hardly anyone
is tuned into that that that is what is
at the center of all of this i believe
and i agree we need some shamans up in
here to like help us figure this stuff
out but i i was thinking first and
foremost just like a straight-up shaman
because they could they could ask so
many questions to people that would
challenge their perceptions it's it's
yeah but but i actually i before i even
i was i was thinking i'm like man you
know because you mentioned psilocybin
and stuff but then i was like you know
what but a monk
you know would also and and a priest and
a rabbi and an imam and like
a buddhist teacher i don't know uh what
do you call a teacher of buddhism
i don't know
i don't know what yeah i don't know but
like a buddhist monk but having a bunch
of different people of different you
know backgrounds but with a background
in the great questions of life
philosophy and theology i think
would be profound for a young person to
experience welcome to the theory of
enchantment is that what it is
fundamentally i got this feeling that uh
yeah illegal making weed illegal yeah
has destroyed our culture it's been a
hundred years so we don't it's kind of
new and yeah all these people like
people in jail people afraid getting
paranoid when they're using
something that already makes them
paranoid you have cannabinoids in your
brain like your brain's ready for it
yeah it's been part of our evolution for
tens of probably hundreds of thousands
of years if not more i don't know do you
think apes were smoking pot yeah or
eating it probably more likely eating it
all and then they would like make big
bushes of it and they'd all sit in a
sweat lodge and light this huge bush of
it on fire and just chill in the sweat
lodge really hot not humans apes
probably were eating it back in the day
and slowly evolved over time got more
intelligent did you ever hear that thing
about like apes ate mushrooms
um i do think that the story of adam and
eve is fundamentally a story about like
two like that's the story of the
development of self-consciousness among
human beings and like the fruit that
they ate were like mushrooms or
something and then they saw themselves
and then they were
uh paranoid which is why they were
ashamed and that's what
but actually was necessary to go it's
necessary to go through the trees was it
the fruit was it called the fruit of
knowledge
yeah the true knowledge of good and evil
yeah wow yeah so it's just like i think
it's like a symbolic story about that
yeah i think you're right that's
interesting that people you know they're
people who believe like you know some
primates
ate some mushrooms started tripping out
and like looking at their hands like
wait a minute yeah woke them up it's
crazy and that's like
not to me i'm not trying to be
disrespectful but there's there's an
element of similarity in adam and eve
and then eating the fruit and knowledge
of good no i actually think it's an
incredibly deep
i think it's a deep and profound story
and i think it's more true because it's
symbolic not because it's literal i
think the fact that it's a symbolic
story makes it more true not less true
yes there's more likely lots of apes
around the world were consuming
psychedelics and kind of realizing that
they were what they were over time i
think they wrote one story about it
well it's interesting because like in
the west our tradition is
uh hebraic and greek
and
adam and eve whereas in the far east
it's the buddha but both stories there's
a garden involved and like
um i always i actually yeah i actually
think that like
the
just as an aside i think that the far
east is in theory
like their wisdom tradition is more
equipped to deal with
abundance as a curse because
the buddha originally was a prince who
was born into a
palace and had everything and his father
wanted to keep him from the truth of the
world he's going to get old he's going
to die he's going to age and all these
things so you know eventually he
discovers this and this is the part of
his path to enlightenment
but i do think it's interesting that
like many stories in different cultures
across space and time have an origin
story that takes place in the garden and
it's this and it's this perennial idea
of what happens when you discover that
there's something outside of yourself
people need like some kind of
fundamental religion
well what do you mean by fundamentals
right right that's a good point i don't
i don't mean like fundamentalists yeah
like extremist i just mean like a base
very very basic and yeah i agree with
that i think people need wisdom
traditions yeah exactly okay so maybe i
should have said fundamental religion
it's too close too close to the word
fundamentalist yeah right um
what does that mean does that mean that
they're never gonna
they're it can never be taken away from
them like they believe it no matter what
i mean i mean like
it's it's the
substrate of reality of how they
understand reality i think i grew up in
a religious home definitely beautiful
also dogmatic in many ways same um very
grateful for that experience because of
where it brought me today but
i at this point i'm seeing everything
that's happening in the world i'm like
my future kids will definitely be raised
with some kind of wisdom tradition
there's no way like
it's gonna be like vapid or like purely
secular it's just not happening my issue
with
a lot of atheists yeah is that and uh
and you can check out the the debate we
had discussion debate we had on religion
we did a member a bonus assignment with
sydney watson and elijah shaffer so i'm
not saying this to be disrespectful to
anybody but a lot of atheists
have a very very
limited understanding of great questions
and so often they'll say something like
they're you know i don't believe there's
a bearded man in the sky watching over
us and i'm like i don't think that's
what christians or muslims believe yeah
i think that's like you actually haven't
sat down had a conversation with a
theologist or uh
or experience any kind of wisdom
tradition as yeah you describe it and so
they have this like
i don't know
um
diminished or maybe that's not the right
word but very very uh malnourished
yeah yeah that's probably a better
misinterpretation of what god is yeah
kind of lack of understanding
in in these great questions because i
think when you start to think about
something i remember when i was like 18
and i'm hanging out with my friends and
they were just stoned off their asses
and i don't i don't smoke i've never
been a smoker and it was a crate it was
one of the craziest conversations about
time the origins of the universe and you
remember it
yeah they were they were sitting there
saying the scribe and then like my
contacts were in too long my eyes were
getting bloodshot so everyone thought i
was stunned anyways i fit in
no but like just like asking these
questions and then we had like someone
pulled up a picture showing like a
linear big bang timeline and then i
started thinking about it and just
imagining the vastness of the universe
and then we were like talking about how
the known universe looks very similar to
a neuron when we like map out and i'm
like
yeah i was actually
but i bring that up because there's a
lot of people who haven't had those
tripped out conversations yeah that make
them
expands their mind's eye as it were to
be like
why would i ever stop and think that god
was like a dude with a beard sitting in
a cloud you know what i mean yeah i was
thinking yesterday about uh
individualism and collectivism a lot and
i'm like i think i'm that when i write i
wrote it on mines i posted this that it
seems like life is like a subjective
experience each person is like life is
for me and for you life is for you but
then i'm like but i feel for like the
the slaves in china and like the kids
being trafficked around the world so
there's like yeah it's like i'm part of
this greater collective like really like
i am and that's what they call holism
holistic and there's a real belief like
holism and then that's like it coincides
with the holofractographic universe that
nasa harriman's been working on it seems
like he's solved einstein's field
equation and he shows that
the universe is connected through the
vacuum yeah so this collective idea is
like yeah we're definitely the same
at some level we're the same organism
we're parts of the same organism but it
just depends on the scale that you're
looking at it i think you know yeah you
know we need to do
we take babies
and then even when they can't talk or
anything
have them just do five years of
philosophy trainings and teachings
having having someone sit down with them
and
start very very with very rudimentary
basics of you know i agree and positive
obviously i'm not saying
go to a baby and pull up you know lock
and start talking about liberalism no i
mean like
starting with a baby and just
being with the baby and
when you want to install some good
philosophy and kids tell them they're
intelligent tell them you're good at
learning and you're really good at that
that is a deep belief a religious belief
that you can instill in a human from an
earlier i just mean like you know asking
questions of the things like what did
you see today
you saw a bird yeah what did the bird
look like what do you think about that
bird have you ever okay
where'd the bird go did you see the you
know like just very simple things and
then once they're a little bit older and
about to go into kindergarten and
they're actually talking and they're
learning basic math and reading now you
can start asking them more serious
questions like where do you think i go
every day what do you think happens
those are the kind of questions that
will like make them think and imagine
and then you tell them and then you can
show them and then as they get older
start laying on the deep deep philosophy
and i imagine if you did that we would
have an individualist nation that works
as a collective when there's emergencies
that needs to
that people trust each other my problem
was learning about philosophies didn't
make me a lot philosophical it was
smoking weed it was the thc and the
self-introspection i always kind of
wanted to be full i was kind of philos
philosophical anyway yeah but people be
like you got to read young you got to
read
this guy and that and i'm like i don't
care man i am connected with god i'm
experiencing it this is like a real
thing and that was the philosophy coming
out of me because of what i was feeling
if you guys are really into this you
should check out the work of jumper vaki
if you're not already familiar with him
he's excellent he's a cognitive
scientist out of university of toronto
and i've learned so much from him he has
a podcast series on spotify called
awakening from the meaning crisis where
he goes through the whole history of
west from the end of the bronze age all
the way up to like the 90s
it's like and he also has to come out
you should invite him he also has like
meditation practices that i follow like
they're free on youtube so anyone it's a
progressive course meaning he teaches a
new thing every monday cool um
what's amazing john what's his last name
verve
e k e v-e-r-v-a-e-k-e you he's excellent
oh cool i'm excited yeah we need you
know what's really funny is because like
i'm i've never done any kind of really
hard drug at all
i drank a bit from when i was like 19 to
20 and i was like
19 to 20. like for a year i drank a lot
yeah
well yeah if you do that then you're
gonna i was drinking when i was 18. you
know i probably started drinking when i
was 16 but not like a drunk right i was
like my first beer and then some parties
when i was 17 and i'd get drunk but i
was never a heavy drinker and then
probably like 19 and 20 was like a party
on the weekends every weekend yeah you
just get drunk you get like a king
alcohol
it does it does as a drug it's one of
the lowest in my opinion
it's just legal but i've never i've
never uh uh i've smoked pot a couple
times i've never done anything else i
have no interest in that i have no
tattoos no piercings acid is very nice
yeah i wouldn't consider it a hard drug
if you do slow doses those things aren't
hard alcohol is much harder but
i say this because i genuinely believe
people
and oh well i'll be careful about how i
say it but
there are certain psychedelic
experiences people have had that i think
have greatly benefited them
specifically the research they're doing
on you know like ptsd yeah other you
know molly with ptsd and tma yeah and so
i'm wondering if there is ketamine too a
very great benefit people would
experience undergoing some kind of
psychedelic there is and the fact that
they made wheat illegal in 19 whatever
was 20 something is terrible because now
people don't understand it they don't
know what the dosages are for it because
a tiny tiny bit is what you're supposed
to do with that stuff like you're gonna
do it not a hit of it not you don't burn
and go
and take this huge thing that's an
overdose that's why things get all
blurry and you're like whoa you're
overdosed that's not intentional use how
much of it are you supposed to take i
mean a tiny tiny i i don't know the
actual microdosage you'd probably have
to talk about they're they're they're
like silicon valley people do this yeah
they micro dose all day that's
interesting but i will say it doesn't
get you i am not discouraging and it was
not an encouragement to anybody i'm
talking about medical research and the
data we've got so far and i think it's
promising and that's why i think this
extended state dmt research is
fascinating
because i feel like this this research
is gonna could lead to like like helping
people a whole lot for sure with like
breaking down the the barriers the walls
their own insecurities and all that
stuff have you smoked dmt much no i've
never puffed on it once it was pretty
cool i would take ayahuasca i i'm one
day oh you will you have i will do i
will do i am planning on doing i lost
yeah and that's the shaman stuff yeah
you know that's the moment like there's
there's
you know you you go to these villages
you might find a shaman he's not going
to be able to tell you anything about
calculus
rocket science maybe
maybe probably not well maybe it's a
rocket scientist flight to south america
but they can they can they can make for
a dope tv show i'll tell you this i
remember when i was a teenager when i
was a kid and i was a teenager that that
quote the only the only thing like true
true wisdom is knowing that you know
nothing yeah socrates when you finally
come to understand what that really
means
because you totally would love john for
vicki it's fantastic
but when when you're young about this
all the time and you're so arrogant not
everybody is but like for me when i was
younger and very arrogant and i was like
that means that's stupid people are dumb
they think they're so smart and then i
get a little bit older and meet more
people and i'm like man i'm so dumb yeah
i was like
i'm the problem wow i realize that much
but it's funny because like he's like
socrates is trying to warn me like
you're not being wise by thinking this
and i'm looking straight at the quote
being like what what a dumbass
and then i'm like later on i'm like man
he was so much smarter than me i'm so
stupid well one of the reasons why some
of these drugs are super cool is because
they result in ego loss and the reason
why people have a hard time
thinking that they don't know everything
is because their identity is attached to
how much they know right and their sense
of self is attached to how much they
know and if they have to wrestle with
the fact oh i don't know something does
that mean i mean my life is meaningless
and then they go down this rabbit hole
so that's ultimately like that's why
like acid is like a great drug because
it affords you a sense of ego loss i
also discovered fashion when i did acid
oh interesting fashion like you got into
doing fashion yeah nice one one of the
reasons i've i've been a big fan of
jordan peterson for a while was when he
went on that jim jeffries show
and he said you know he's like i don't
think that you know you should be
forcing a person to say certain words
and you know like telling them how they
should run their businesses and who they
should invite in and then he was like
but don't you think it was a good thing
that they forced businesses and civil
rights movement to desegregate
and jordan just went
yeah maybe i was wrong about that like
just very simply like oh hey good point
yeah so many people would be like what
how did no i was yeah
it's just like yeah i see what you're
saying yeah that's a good point yeah
humble i'm like that's that's the sign
of somebody who's actually thinking
listening and not so concerned with
himself he's more concerned with what is
true what is great the great questions
yeah in search of the truth and the
answer as we know is 42. yeah of course
it's true
what
wait what did you say
the answer to the great question is 42.
what does that mean hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy did you ever read that
book no why is everyone insisting that i
read this book maybe maybe because you
shouldn't he's wonderful in the book
they're like what is the meaning of the
universe they asked this giants no no no
they said what is the great question
what is the great question or what is
the answer to the great question yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the computer at the
end is like you didn't ask what the like
you didn't tell me what
i have never done either but i played
the video game
it was one of those texts i'm not the
only one
so basically in the movie earth is
destroyed to make way for a super
highway yep and they're given like only
like an hour's warning like
your planet will be destroyed to make
way for the galactic super highway we're
sorry for the inconvenience have a nice
day and then kill everybody okay but
then later
like i guess later i can't remember like
a group or aliens realize earth was
actually a special project to calculate
the answer to the good question so they
have to rebuild the earth and remake it
and everyone comes back and whatever
interesting and then they go to the
computer what's the answer or 42 and
they're like what like haven't you
didn't give me the actual question how
many do you want is that how it ends
oh it is a trilogy it is a trilogy with
five parts wait one which tells you
leave it to the british
i think that's british comedy douglas
reaction yes
there's a couple other there's a couple
other movies that i like and so
i think it's called any anything anytime
with simon uh peg peg yeah
i don't know that one
and that's also sci-fi
yeah it's like aliens um
to decide whether a race they discover
is worthy absolutely anything absolutely
anything grant a random entity on the
planet absolute power oh
that's so that's great that's a great so
simon pegg just all of a sudden has the
ability to do anything what would be the
first thing you do with absolute power
uh give it away that me too yeah
i would give it to someone or just make
it you would lose no i wouldn't
what would you do what was the first
thing you do
ascend to a higher plane what is that
what does that mean perceive the
universe from external dimensions and
explore and just watch and understand
and learn and try to whenever i could
and then what what see here's the
problem with your answer
give the power away i would disperse it
i would i would turn it to zero and all
the power no no i would you would just
yeah you would disperse it when you say
give it away
how do you to whom do you give it for me
it's like
i just go and i'd go to mars
i wouldn't interfere with anything i'd
observe i don't even have to sing
presence would be an interference
why would it be because it's physics
if i if i have absolute power i would
phase out of sync with existence this is
this okay well so this is where i would
speaking we're suspending physics in
this hypothetical absolute power
did you mean like political power
no absolutely no because we're talking
about a movie where the dude can
literally do anything god like can you
define absolutely
just in the movie yeah literally
anything absolutely so he can
go i'm gonna chill on the sun he can
like well i mean yes you could burn your
body a lot if you wanted let me i'll
spoil the movie for you guys okay all
right he actually so the aliens
you think the test is that they want to
see what you do with absolute power
and earth fails the test because simon
pegg ends up being a good guy
who gives the power away and doesn't
want to
be this powerful entity and the aliens
are outraged because of course the only
thing someone should do with absolute
power is cause pain and suffering and
control and dominate and only a few
races have ever actually used the
galactic power in this way so then they
try to destroy the earth but i guess
like i can't remember exactly what
happens he made his dog send like his
intelligent
and then the dog he made his dog
intelligent he gave the power to his
dogs didn't want it but then i i can't
remember but basically what happens is
the power actually destroys the source
of the power itself and kills all the
evil aliens before they can destroy
earth right that's why you give it away
because if you don't give it away it'll
destroy you
like the one ring if i exactly
if i absolutely
i would just go to higher dimensions
they would be coming after you
who would the nazgul nobody
i don't know i don't know that far i
don't know man i just have you seen
doctor strange i love doctors it's one
of my favorite it is my favorite movie
yeah
it's one of my favorite in the marvel
universe did you just watch the new what
if
the new what if on disney plus there's a
show called what if oh no watch that it
is it takes the marvel cinematic
universe stories and says what if in
this universe x happened
so in the latest one they said what if
oh man i'm disappointed in this episode
it says what if doctor strange lost his
heart instead of his hands
so you know he would die no no no no no
no his his emotional heart oh so here's
what happens
spoiler alert if you want to wait can we
like can we just flush this out on our
own and not because if it's sucked then
it's going to go down
i just think they missed the best
version of the story all right let me
break it down for you guys because you
know i'm i i could fix all these movies
of course you have ultimate power
spoiler alert for those that want to
watch what if i enjoy the show
they could do better but it's a good
show um this doctor strange episode i'm
gonna give spoilers okay so here's what
happens
in this version of the doctor strange
story if those aren't familiar in the
movie doctor strange is this egotistical
super famous neuro neurosurgeon and he's
driving to get an award and he tries to
bypass a semi on the highway in a storm
and then you know there's an accident he
flies off the road crashes and his hands
get crushed
now he can't work anymore so he spends
all of his money trying to get surgeries
and then finally once he's broke he
seeks at the mystic arts and then
becomes the sorcerer's supreme okay in
the what if show
christine goes with him christine of
course is his love interest
in the car accident he survives and she
dies
because of her death he questions his
life and decides to seek out answers in
the mystic arts as to the nature of life
and becomes source her supreme okay and
then saves the you know you know the
plan and everything as the movie goes
but with the time stone the eye of
agamotto he can go back in time and save
christine
but every time he tries she dies in a
different way she gets shot a building
explodes something happens
and then the ancient one comes to the
past because he keeps interfering and
she's still alive in the past and says
this is an absolute point in time that
can't be changed if she doesn't die you
don't pursue the mystic arts right and
because you don't dormammu wins and you
can't exist thus in this universe for it
to exist she has to have died
so what happens is
strange becomes evil
he says i will break the the absolute
point in time by any means becomes darth
vader yes and so in the end he destroys
the universe and you know what really
busted me up
the missed opportunity what is the miss
opportunity first i'll point out the
reason i brought it i i want to bring it
up is
the main the narrator of the show is the
watcher i love that guy he just watches
yeah but doctor so in all of these
different what if episodes you can see
the watcher in the background watching
oh that's creepy no but no one knows
cool martial because regular people
don't have that understanding but dr
strange does so dr strange actually
calls out the watcher watching him do it
and he says you're a god help me fix
this and he goes i am not a god you did
this to yourself and he goes no but
you're here you can help it was amazing
to see him
be the care one character who knew the
watcher was watching because he's dr
strange he's an awesome character
you know what really busted me up
the opportunity was so good
it was so good and they missed it
let me tell you what should have
happened because i was like oh i think i
know what's going to happen
christine dies and no matter what he
does he can't save her
it's an absolute point in time that sets
him on the path to become doctor strange
so in the end he shouldn't have become
evil he should have kept trying and he
should have defied this the ancient one
and said no i will never give up and the
watcher should have said
there is one universe
in which
christine doesn't die
it's the universe where you destroy your
hands and your life and everything
you're famous for
all of your wealth and lose everything
yeah and then he says
i will sacrifice everything i am and
i've ever achieved if it means she lives
and then it kicks off the original
doctor strange movie
where he caused he caused his own hands
to be destroyed you're going to need to
buy marvel
i agree you're right no that's that's
that's totally that should have been it
like he calls on the watcher instead of
becoming darth vader he would have
become jesus can the watcher do that
though is the i don't know watcher
the watcher does talk to strange and the
watcher is the one who sees all these
universes and strange could have said
please help me if the universe is just
being destroyed and he says there's
nothing i can do
and then the watcher could have said in
one universe
does the watcher ever give advice like
that historically i don't know
but maybe maybe the one thing
so then maybe the curse is to always
witness and never participate but like
everybody like still like picard you
know every once in a while you better
hold on but he still talked to doctor
strange so at the very least it could
have been
that
as things are falling apart he remembers
what the ancient once said about being
driven to the mystic arts and then he
realizes he has to have a sacrifice that
drives him so he decides to sacrifice
his entire being in life his hands his
work his career his wealth
to save christine's life and then he
uses the aggievagamoto one more time
and she's not in the car anymore and
then he crashes and destroys his hands
and she lives yeah you nailed it that
would have been he would have said
because then it starts the movie off
he did it to himself yeah for a good
reason oh but then i have a question
though doesn't that change the the
actual original movie because in the
original movie he was in fact
egotistical so wouldn't that doesn't be
weird because if he's really doing it
deep down because he's not egotistical
no no all that like the driving and the
thing happens when he's like in his
egotistical state he would go back in
time and set the path forward where he
destroys his own life erasing his
timeline and creating a new timeline
where
he's still egotistical his hands are
destroyed he still seeks out the answers
and then comes to better understand
reality
never knowing what really happened with
the first iteration of christine's death
so it's like a time loop that just ends
itself
okay i just thought that would have been
amazing that would have been amazing
yeah you do need to buy marvel man
buy it man anyway doctor strange awesome
why are we why are we talking about
doctor strange um because i like doctor
strange i forgot his i forgot the
connection i forgot the connection we
were making oh oh because you can't
because you cannot have absolute power
and that was the whole point of um
that other movie
now the end of doctor strange right
where he goes to bargain with death
and the doorman
okay
uh well
okay but his his
wise colleague
says
you always have to pay you always have
something to pay and i i think that's
why you can't have absolute power the
bill comes due always yeah that's legit
my favorite movie i love that it's a
great movie it's an incredible film
i i i just love the idea of this
narcissistic
doctor who's like fundamental belief in
science and then he discovers hidden
meaning and truth after he lets go of
himself and goes and becomes a monk and
then becomes this great and wise hero
yeah i'm excited for the new spider-man
movie because he's like the main
oh is he he's yeah so uh the trailer
shows peter parker asking strange to do
a spell to erase everyone's memory oh
and so dr strange is doing cool stuff my
favorite marvel mcu character is doctor
strange i love that movie i'm excited
for the next cumberbatch man yeah
fantastic actor yeah oh and i was going
to say one of my favorite movies is this
the first new star trek i don't know
what was it called not into the darkness
sort of the first one oh also with
cumberbatch also with cumberbatch yeah
he plays khan i think that's into
darkness isn't it oh is that the second
one of the new ones either way
cumberbatch slayed it the best part of
that movie i loved him that was my
introduction to cumberbatch too but it's
like khan was wasn't ricardo maltobon or
whatever it was i don't know who that is
they just like
i guess bennett counter-back is a good
he was not a good julian assange i
thought that was awful but he is a
really good doctor she had a beer dog
boy says i was like what the heck yeah
when he says his name
and then and then alternate timeline
spock is like
oh snap yeah it was ricardo montemon
yeah yeah yeah let's read some super
chats from everybody wow we're a little
late we went a little bit late because
we don't do the bonus segments anyway
and i really wanted to talk about that
doctor strange episode because it was
eating me alive i'm glad you did yeah no
that's good that's a good resolution
man can we just make that because that's
what i want to watch yeah
i want to believe that in the end he
like he became corrupted but then truly
realized what it meant to be a hero and
then created a new timeline is it that
you can't take one of your favorite
people like descending into evil
darkness
you can't take it i felt like it was out
of character to be honest
well you know the shakespearean uh
tragedies
are always
not what you expect it's it's not just
that i'm fine watching doctor strange go
totally evil and then say oh no what
have i done but there was no payoff for
it it was just like well we we we were
told he was going to destroy the
university if he did he didn't karen did
it anyway and then universe got
destroyed i'm like what was the lesson
what was what did we what happened other
than just
it's the end of the universe he wasn't
thrown into like despair he was yeah
yeah it's like the universe collapses
and then he's just like trapped in a gem
or something and christine he saves
christine but then she gets you know she
disintegrates in the collapsing universe
how do you feel about star wars sorry to
keep coming back
the original star wars yeah great
the prequels silly but fun the
sequels just the worst trash i've ever
seen how do you feel about
darth vader's arc
as a character i think i think it's so
fascinating it's really really good but
i know that you have to watch clone wars
to get the full grasp of his
transformation okay the movies
themselves don't do it justice sure and
i was not a fan of more plot driven in
the movies than character driven i think
a lot about it because i think using the
dark side is is
necessary yeah um and for sure we have
to be more we have to not fear it but
but be familiar with it to control it so
that it doesn't take over this is what
shadow works
awful
awful
like have you ever played knights of the
old republic
when you meet the gray jedi and they're
like i dated someone who said that the
jedi were awful they are religious
zealots
no longer do
wow you'll have to go deeper on why you
think that's awful so the sith are bad
because they covet power and they're
willing to kill to gain more the jedi
are bad because they're dogmatic and
that's fair
it's it's a dogmatic religious religion
of celibacy and and monk stuff is and
that's that's that's fine to an extent
yeah but not when they wield power and
try to assassinate a chancellor because
they think he's a bad guy but he was a
bad guy so what they knew they could
feel it
and that and the problem is
it's it's very obvious if mace windu did
not try to kill
palpatine at that moment i agree i agree
with that they would have won but
there's zealotry i don't think he's
people he must be
to kill him yeah yeah i agree with that
and they they lost their way i don't
think they can kill them no what did
anakin say it's not that's the best way
you're supposed to arrest him yeah and
he said he's too dangerous
well that's the dilemma that's the
dilemma because the sith lord was also
like an elected member
so the problem is the religious zealots
who would throw out the rule of law for
their own personal religious drive of
what is truly evil
and that so and anakin watched that
happen and he's like it's not the jedi
way he should be tried yes they should
have arrested him and told the world
he's a sith lord what should we do and
yes they had to prove to the people
and and resist the powers of the dark
side and it would have been the
difficult choice but instead mace windu
was like i don't care it's easy i'll
kill him now
but wasn't he was mace windu under
threat of being killed in that moment
remember because the other the palpatine
whatever i don't i don't think he was
blocking the force lightning
i disagree in fact he could have said
anakin helped me subdue him and anakin
probably would have and he would have
said i don't know
anakin said he was almost turnt by that
point yes but he said i need him alive
and so mace could have stopped to learn
from him yeah and then maybe mace didn't
know this mace didn't know what was
going on but why do you don't just i'm
not trying to i'm not trying to defend i
think i think it's more of a dilemma
than it is like cut and try i i think
it's more of a dilemma what happened
then the chancellor used the attempted
assassination to justify the extreme
expansion of powers and to hunt down the
jedi
if i'd been a jedi
one incident to cause that that's absurd
if a great jedi had walked in and
slaughtered the emperor in that moment
and ended the sith chancellor the
chancellor and ended the sith
what would have what would have been the
problem with that
you have to so you're coming at this
point uh this is this this situation
from a state of absolute knowledge good
and evil yeah imagine you walk into a
room
and you see two people and one's on the
ground saying help me please help me
please and the guy says don't don't
listen to him he's evil and then what
would you do you read the script baby no
i i'd use the force no i'm just kidding
i don't know what i stopped the guy
who's about to kill somebody that'll be
a weird weirdo and so so the issue is
anakin says it's not the jedi way mace
window said it should have said you're
right
and i agree with that but i don't think
that's a that's a
um
you know a folly on all the jedi i just
kind of felt like for anakin to
instantly be like i hate you to obi-wan
i was like
no that's that was unbelievable did luke
use the dark side yes which is i think
in george lucas who wrote it disagrees
but yeah because he was learning it from
um
wasn't he learning it from the little
green man yoda yeah
he was using the doctor he was learning
to like
to like fact-check me on this but he was
learning to channel to channel it he was
channeling the light side yoda was
talking about the light
no but when he went against his father
he could have killed him but he didn't
and that's how and he was he was like
almost driven to do that and so he he
resisted he was like in the face
i think he resisted the light side by
being able to accept his
father oh
i see yeah you're saying the light
should have ended the darkness exactly
interesting
but by by doing so it ultimately
converted vader back to the light wow
right exactly so it was
enchantment wasn't
he resisted his own impulse to convert
him and because of that he converted wow
so basically daryl davis was inspired
exactly i was just gonna say daryl
that's also what daryl davis did that's
also daryl we should read super chats
all right harry toe says i'm so excited
i found a farmer that will let me put my
finger in a cow's mouth he didn't ask
any questions i thought that was strange
find a better different farmer talk to
your farmer
blue sea says i loved when chloe was on
dark horse with brett and they discussed
her theory of enchantment what an
awesome mind you have chloe
thank you
jesse meek says sacramento has a teacher
that openly promotes anti-fun the
classroom and even offers extra credit
to students for attending protests and
such shout out to amazing tubers liberty
doll and the philosophy
philosopher philosopher sorry
all right let's see we got
revan sheridan says tim i live in the
deep south in the new orleans area and i
uh i was being taught crt in elementary
back in the late 90s i was taught black
women are the most oppressed and it's my
fault
are you from new orleans yeah do you
have similar experiences with that stuff
and then no interesting
jimmy kendo says i agree with her
definition there you go
ron quay says chloe is classically woke
the way it should be wokism as it's
known today is just neoquism i remember
when being woke meant seeing the actual
truth not using race to bait and make
money
well there you go i like that
jenny's says does chloe have a
curriculum for homeschoolers
so anyone can go to theory of
enchantment.com
and enroll in our online course so it
doesn't matter who you are it's a
self-paced course anyone can access it
right on very cool oh so uh yeah we we
we haven't covered this story yet we've
all been posting about it andrew
lage says south australia is forcing
returning citizens to download an app
that will send them a notification and
within 15 minutes they must go to the
specified place and take a photo with
their face on it if not the cops come do
you hear this
it's crazy
however
my understanding is how it works is you
have the app
you'll get a notification saying you
have 15 minutes to post a photo from the
location you're at using geolocation
which means if you claim to be at a
house in this particular area you take a
picture of yourself it's geotagged with
the area and your face confirmed you're
good
geolocation spoofing apps are free
and i knew this is where you're going to
put you anywhere you want so
it's a terrible plan for the government
it won't work i i was thinking about
this today
while i was in the mri machine because
guess what you can't have in a freaking
mri machine literally anything metal
including your phone i was thinking
about tonight's show when tim doesn't
really look much at his phone because
he's doing a show
how dare a police force think that this
is okay absolutely insane
all right odd ninja says hey tim and
crew first super chat to ian if a human
male gets a human female pregnant is she
carrying a growing human
uh
you mean like right after like 10 10
seconds after the pregnancy technically
not yet the question is is the question
is um i don't know when you would
consider the the fetus uh a human i'm
not sure what that medical issue is
yeah i mean if you're asking for medical
definitions i'm not the guy that would
be able to answer that you have to look
that up is it a growing human
it depends on what stage it is when do
you start to consider the zygote a human
is is later in the pregnancy human
father human mother is she carrying
something that will that is growing into
a human
yeah it might seem like that yeah i
don't know
the sperm human yeah is there a sperm a
growing human it says because it's going
to eventually impregnate the question is
pregnant yeah but the pregnancy doesn't
mean that the kid's going to ever be
born it could that kid could be an
abrupt
accidental termination you know you
never know and you could get hit by a
car so no no that zygote might die
before it ever becomes a human yeah no
she's not human are you growing old we
won't
i don't know how to answer that question
too there's solar age and there's
genetic agents are you growing
genetically i'm regenerating oh my gosh
i'm getting i'm genetically because i
don't want to you still want to admit it
all right to tim ask knowles about
getting in contact with ted cruz to come
on the show i thought about that
super fun pulling strings with our past
guests
i think ted cruz would have stood up for
himself in the cancun thing
i think he like
that was dumb it's culture war stupidity
tell him about it
like i need a vacation follow me on
twitter yeah exactly all right salty
racer says i think the shadow work is an
excellent idea problem is that some
people literally slap in the face to
change their behavior this has stopped
and it's causing serious problems i
disagree
i don't agree with that yeah i don't i
was gonna say i don't know about that
yeah i think that actually will just
like when you approach someone as an
enemy you you solidify their their their
if a person already
is
acting out of a lack of self-worth and
you slap them so to speak
you're actually going to uh deepen that
sense of low self-esteem you can't make
a change like that unless you're
slapping yourself in the face
simultaneously you yeah it does
josh oh my gosh says chloe what do you
think about the idea of opt in taxes for
social legislation for example know
nothing about that i know i thought it
was like a very i don't know yeah but
here's what they say
i'll read it
supporters of abortion pay taxes for it
opposers don't tim check out the singer
joff castellucci on youtube deep deep
singing voice cool
i don't know what your general thoughts
i have none all right there you go your
thoughts
brandon freeman says tim please ask her
if she's a marxist and get a yes or no
no i am
not i think you actually said that early
on like you're critical of you know
critical theory i'm critical of critical
theory i'm also critical of the marxist
take or what seems to be marx's take on
um
like
saying that like what's driving
certain people in elite institutions to
crt or to wokeness is because it's
financially successful i don't think
that that's actually what's happening i
don't think that's a
sufficient driver
and that's a very
marxist idea ultimately joshua hickey
says white crt people are white
supremacists they believe they're
inherently above the level due to their
skin color usually they're just
undisciplined and spoiled people who
haven't earned what they've been given
and they know it
well that's interesting one of the
things that i've said and carl benjamin
has said is that many of these white wok
people are white supremacists with
guilty consciences
okay
let me think about that for a second
but
i don't know
i don't know about that i mean
what what is the role of guilt in this
particular context so the
self-flagellation that we spoke about so
so one of the stories i tell a bit too
much sorry audience for being a divorce
but uh was when i was in the north
dakota pipeline protests
when i was when i was there when i was
and i met a guy who told me that
um
asian culture was influenced by or so
here's what he said i said i had a
meeting he said what do you mean you
have a meeting i was like i got to be in
la in a couple days so i gotta leave
soon and he goes
that's colonial thinking to fly to l.a
while i was driving i mean i could drive
to l.a but he was like to have a
scheduled meeting he was like the native
americans don't have that they wake up
when they wake up they they know not
this again and what i said was i said
i was like what are you talking about i
was like how's that colonial thinking
what does that mean he goes like the
european colonizers brought that here it
didn't exist before they brought it here
because the native americans didn't have
it and i said
dude chinese people have schedules they
wake up to farm and he goes well let's
be honest it was the white people who
brought that to him and i was like are
you kidding me you're gonna sit here and
tell me dude we invented the cup the
compass a thousand years before you guys
did yeah that's true
and uh
how did he take that
he he got flustered i called him a white
supremacist i said i am not gonna sit
here and listen to a white supremacist
tell me that my culture which was
thousands of years more advanced than a
thousand years more advanced than yours
is is
for everything that my ancestors did you
had nothing to do with it and then
everyone kind of looked at him and he
was like whoa but that's the the idea is
their spouse they believe that the white
europeans made everything i do think
there's an irony to this and i do think
that one of the
one of my objections to
like ta-nehisi coates wrote an article
in atlantic a few years ago
um called the first white president i
think that was the name of it where he's
talking about donald trump
and he
basically argued that white supremacy
was i forgot the particular line so i
apologize if i misquote this is a
paraphrase but he was basically like
white supremacy is cosmic in nature
and my thing was if you actually believe
that then you actually believe in white
supremacy
you would have to believe
that white people are in fact omnipotent
in order to believe that it is cosmic
and everywhere
in nature yeah and so
i yeah that that story resonates with me
and i think it's one of the blind spots
and the ironies
going on in a lot of these arguments
yeah i see a lot of people mentioning we
in the check cause i said we invented
yes i'm part asian that's the point is
that i was sitting in front of a guy who
was overtly white and yes i am still
mostly white german irish british and uh
i think that's it for the most part but
the point i was making was like this
dude was directly insulting my asian
heritage and so i'm like to reference my
ancestors and the work they did for you
to come here obviously i understand you
know uh
like european colonization this guy was
just a white supremacist
all right scott james pilkington says
greetings shim cast i smashed it for ian
i'm very much looking forward to you
looking into the freedom phone my phone
is only two years old due to
all the bloat it's almost useless how to
fix bloatware
flash the phone and get like a new
operating system graphene graphene oats
i've heard it's good yeah it's good and
i i'm saying that because you know
you're ian and i like graphene
and that's right um
right now there is a sad ian
and by simply smashing the like button
you can ensure that today assadigan will
not be said any longer get your graphene
here and now
also um the freedom phone thing is going
to be a while they're on backorder until
like november i think now so give us a
few months on this one and the problem
is we can't expedite it so it's like
yeah we're not going through eric on
this we're going to go through the
company to get so we're not getting
potemkin phones basically we don't want
things so it's been tweaked to look
right but but maybe there's an easier
way to do it is if somebody gets a
freedom phone
we can work with you
uh or your phone or whatever and
something like that the issue is that if
we go to them and say hey can we get
phones well then we're getting phones
from them and you can't trust it we
can't ask them for phones and we can't
even ask for an expedited phone hey here
are the people we're getting phones
delivered to you no because then they're
going to send them clean you know fixed
phones or whatever or
it's it's compromise in the security
so
yeah well it just could take some time
well that's a good sign that they're
they're on back order doing extremely
well yeah i'm glad they're doing well uh
okay so uh christopher lambert says
george carlin and the use on context
doing it again special 1990. all right
so you were so i was not born we're not
born and i was four
all right c hennessey says tim kevin
pafrath is the real guy you should be
looking at for california governor race
dude's jfk style dem leading is in state
polls
he also know he's also known as meet
kevin on youtube he should be able to
get the dumb votes i did see that um
he's not beating larry elder
in in aggregate there may be a poll
showing him uh ahead but he is doing
really really well and it does seem like
an interesting guy i you know i i've
seen some of the videos and some of the
stuff he's talking to my problem is i
don't i don't trust voting for the
democrats after the 2018 midterms
they promised in 31 districts they would
get away from the culture war and focus
on real issues for the families and as
soon as they got in they went to nancy
pelosi and says what shall we do my
liege and she said impeach trump don't
you guys i find there's a lot of cross
contamination between governors and uh
congress
like
like if a governor is democratic is that
really that big of a deal yes relative
to their influence or are they kind of
autonomous when california
proposed uh i don't know if you saw this
was it prop
42 or something i don't know pop six
they proposed removing the
non-discrimination clause from their
constitution that barred discrimination
the base of race national origin sex
from their uh why
because they argued that it inhibited
their ability to engage in anti-racism
yes because
anti-racist discrimination
is good in ibram kennedy's book
all of the national democrats were
endorsing it
okay that's a hyperbolic many national
democrats and democrats from other
states were endorsing so you think that
that it says democrat is more of a
warning like hey check this gu you vet
this guy because he's identifying with
this weird party not that if someone
puts democrat on their shirt they're
necessarily a bad person what happens to
people like kimberly klasik and billy
prempe
they can't get money from the party they
can't get support from the party it's
hard to fundraise
the par so so people in the party
regardless of whether it's a mayor or a
state rep or a governor
are still beholden to the dnc
the democratic national committee i
think is right yeah because they want
the access to fundraisers the data
the promotion
so they're plugging into the so a
governor party member is a party member
i don't like the republicans either to
be honest you know
i don't like political parties me either
yeah i agree
i agree
all right let's see we got you
taserus says ian rights can be thought
of simply as the ways you can be wronged
they can be derived by observing how
life grows and how it can be
stunted i don't know about that one i
don't know we've been having kind of an
ongoing debate about what our rights
what our natural rights also about
abortion which is why where that came
from earlier okay so i'm of the opinion
that natural rights exist
and are
some people would say granted to by god
the other way to describe that is just
that they're an intrinsic part of being
ian thinks that rights are cultural and
don't inherently exist
can you split the difference between the
two probably yeah i feel like um
the americans were like we're going to
set up a system where
we have what we think of as like rules
like rights based on the christian bible
so they built the bill of rights
and they told us it was given to us by
god inherent inalienable nothing they
ever did had anything to do with it was
just there to begin with and they're
kind of protecting it
i don't think so because if we got a new
government they'd start telling us your
right is to wake up in the morning your
right is to worship the dear leader
these have always been your rights your
grandfather fought for these rights and
then eventually you're like my rights
have always been so like it seems like
cultural brainwashing
well is it possible that
one could just be wrong and the other
could be right it is possible that there
is like an objective reality and there's
a way of behavior that
serves our propagation and the species
and these might be those we might be
onto something with that yeah okay but i
i think without the american military to
enforce it they don't exist it's not
real sure well it it
so is your definition of real
enforceable yeah if it's not enforceable
it won't be there
hmm
okay that's interesting i don't know
how to feel about that i think that
rights exist we have many many rights
and governments try to infringe upon
them for the sake of
cohesion power yeah because isn't that
an argument for power all the way down
basically it's terrifying but i feel
like that's real the reality is
the person with the big weapon has
always run the show yeah but that
doesn't why does that mean
that that's true but that doesn't mean
that one doesn't have inalienable rights
just because they're not being enforced
or why does that necessarily mean that
so like they're not inaudible because if
they want to say you don't have them
anymore then you don't i'll i'll ask you
this question yeah
would you be upset
with a deer
for
kicking the coyote that was attacking it
no because the deer has a right to
defend itself
sure
the right exists we recognize it we
don't fault the animal yeah would you be
upset with someone with like a woman
this is a weird analogy yeah because the
way you said the deer has the right to
defend itself it's kind of a misuse of
the word right in the term of natural
rights that we're talking about
well it doesn't the deer doesn't have a
natural just the deer defending itself
isn't really it's it's not exercising a
right it's just defending itself would
you be upset yeah would you if i
if a person was being beaten in the
street
and a guy was just pummeling him and
then he grabbed a wrench off the ground
and smacked the guy in the face and
killed him would you blame the guy who
was being beaten no he has a right to
defend himself right well god yeah i
mean he should if he wants to survive he
better defend himself and so the way the
law works is that we recognize an
affirmative defense uh for murder
self-defense is not murder
it's not a crime for you're free to go
you have a right to defend yourself
so there are many rights that we
recognize and there are many rights the
government tries to take away from you
but the right to keep and bear arms is
fundamentally the right to self-defense
in this country not all countries have
are you saying that if a person if the
government didn't support a person
defending themselves then that person no
longer has the right to defend correct
like in north korea if a soldier were to
kick a guy on the ground and the guy
tried to fight back they'd execute him
on the spot that's right and because he
has no right so if you're being i think
you guys are defining rights differently
exactly that's where we can so
yeah so the problem is that even when i
read ian the definition he didn't agree
well you read it to me and then you
stated a different definition as the
definition of the word it's on video
you were talking you said ethics in the
definition that you didn't say ethics
when you were redefining i i read a
large paragraph giving you a very
intricate explanation of where ethic
natural laws applied and why and then
you started nitpicking it so i broke it
down to
like
fundamental uh
truths that are inhere freedoms that are
inherent to living beings because no
matter what definition i give you you
would change the definition
this is a clearly a great question yeah
what are natural rights are they given
by god i mean in the constitution it
says god gave it to you and you're like
uh i'm an atheist let me ask you guys
questions is the american government
full of it because i'm an atheist let me
ask you guys a question yeah if a
man uh was walking down the street my
name was his own business and a cop
pulls up
for no reason runs up to him and starts
mercilessly beating him with the with
the knight with his with billy club and
the man is on the ground and then he's
being beaten begging please stop and
then he leans over and grabs a wrench
gets up and cracks the cop killing him
instantly would you blame the guy on the
ground no would you i mean i can't i
can't these are ridiculous situations
you're creating dude
there's no context i don't know what
that i can't blame either of those guys
for that i don't know what's going on i
gave you the context but you just gave
me a limited from the moment i saw it
start to happen to me all right let's
try it again what cause let's try it
again let's try again if a man was
selling lucy cigarettes outside of a
bodega and the cops came up and put him
in a chokehold and he was screaming i
can't breathe
and then he grabs a wrench and swings it
hits the cop killing him instantly would
you blame the guy being choked no
blame him for what for killing the cop
jeez that's a tough one because if the
cop if if if you attack a tiger and the
tiger bites your face would you i blame
the guy that attacked the tigers would
you blame a man
wouldn't a chokehold be blame them both
you've got to blame them both if you
stick your hand in a tiger's mouth and
it bites your finger it's your fault and
it's a tiger i can understand both
argument but i would still mostly blame
the cop so that was the eric garner case
yeah
and you still okay fine he defend i mean
self-defense isn't it's not okay
self-defense i'm not saying that the
reason it's okay to defend your life is
because you have a right you have to
defend your life to survive now we built
a legal now you understand infarction
for that is that the infarction is that
the right word for infarction is a
yeah it's blood loss to a muscle yeah
all right well i want to i want to make
that a political word i like that yeah
let's do it the formation or development
of an infarct
yeah an infarct we'll get to that later
yeah so i don't want to waste these
super chatters times because people are
giving us money right now the reason why
i asked the question about the cop is
because
you recognize you wouldn't blame someone
for defending themselves if cop was
mercilessly beating them right and they
took it to person's life and their
attempt was to defend themselves but the
state would probably still arrest you
and charge you right
because they would in fact fight
immunity
well i think among other things but
that's mostly about lawsuits though i
think the issue here is that culturally
the police department would say
too bad mf or you killed the cop we
don't care why
and as much as we as human beings if we
recognize a situation in which a
legitimately innocent person in full
context was innocent being attacked by a
criminal police officer we would every
person a conservative would be like well
of course that cop's a bad guy
the state probably would disregard and
probably still arrest them but they
would be biased against them they
wouldn't care but the guy has the right
to self-defense this is what point
you're going towards now that's good now
that's why we built our government is to
protect that idea but it wasn't my
argument is that it wasn't
given to us by god it was these dudes
ben franklin thomas jefferson
problem with the god piece you know yeah
thinking that it's inalienable and it
can't be ever taken away freaks me out
that's what it means that's not what it
is
ineligible doesn't mean it can't be
infringed upon
it seems to people seem to think that if
you're out in the middle of the
wilderness you still have those rights i
don't think so you do no what do you
mean if you're naked in the woods you
don't have like the right to
self-defense and the right to free
speech like dude
you do
you can pick them up
you still can do those things but you
don't have a right there's no i still
don't understand what your definition of
writing
is like it's like well what is the
definition of rights things that are
related to your abilities that are given
to you by god this is what natural oh it
is natural to the dignity of
of what it means to be human freedoms
that are inherent to life fundamental uh
like the it's like a part of the
sacredness of what it means to be human
in this society
in order for life to function there are
it is in order for life to function
certain things have to happen and as as
human beings and as all life strives to
survive we recognize that life life does
certain things in fact in the definition
of life when they describe it it
propagates and it i believe defense or
or the the attempt to survive
is one of them no i could be wrong about
that one the the challenge i have with
your understanding is it seems that it
would be
easily devolving into relativism
it is and that's why people are going
crazy right now and railing against the
us government because the government's
like blindly being like
like okay i get it we think that this is
the best way
here and now because we're in it we're
in it we haven't seen a better system
yet so to us this is the right this is
the right way but it doesn't mean it's
the only way or ever will be or ever was
i think you're confusing like rights and
privileges i've seen people be like you
can't do that to me i have the right and
i'm like dude you have to stand in front
of that right like you have to make sure
health care is not a human right
right
that that statement makes literally no
sense like you ban me off youtube i have
the right to that no you should have
built a website to protect yourself
because
you don't have the right you think so
you think the government is protecting
your rights because they say they are no
but here's what you misunderstood you've
got to protect your own rights and
create them so uh
the right to free speech exists the
right to expression exists there are
some limits on causing harm to others
because now you're infringing on their
right to life and they're they have the
right to defense but when a massive
multinational corporation takes up all
the land we actually have battled this
out in the courts we've decided that
publicly owned private spaces
you are required to allow free speech so
occupy wall street for instance was only
possible because the people went on
private property and the private company
said you have no right to free speech on
my property and the government the
people and the president in the courts
was
actually if you're occupying the common
space as a private owner you can't take
away someone's right to free speech so
youtube bans people banks d bank people
and they should us government hasn't
done a thing about it because arguments
against censorship because it can't the
government cannot that's not only is it
not infringing on those rights
corporations are and the government
can't do anything about it they can what
can they do so first their section 230
reform or section 230 enforcement which
they're not doing why well right now
democrats have the majority and
republicans have no will republicans
were too stupid to do anything about it
from 2016 and on and now they're all
being banned and blacklisted and they
don't care because most of them were
neocons unipartists anyway
now you have the issue of just enforce
section 230 never was this law intended
to allow twitter to arbitrarily create
editorial guidelines on what opinions
you're allowed to have youtube doesn't
come to me and say we're concerned about
the safety of individuals so you can't
talk about donald trump's election that
makes no sense they have editorial
guidelines now are there other places
you can go technically yes but if there
is a massive major stadium or all of the
space in in in the center of the town is
being occupied or or owned by one person
we have already determined that
privately owned public spaces must
protect the free speech rights of an
individual all we need now is for the
willpower in any politician to enforce
it the government has the power and
facebook is terrified of this that's why
facebook has been having meetings with
politicians trying to be like please
don't regulate us because we know you
can do it people begging for daddy to
fix it is freaking me out the people
like a politician could fix it for me
the government could do it for like dude
these are your rights this is not
alexandria cortez's
version of your rights this is yours and
no no corporation or government state is
going to make that is going to keep that
for you that's up to you and your
friends and there's a lot of reading
you'd have to do for us to like make a
substantive conversation here i'm sure
we should have experts on but i mean we
like i think the people who have watched
this have researched too much
and for you to enter this conversation
with this lack of understanding would be
like
you know someone who's never read a math
book trying to explain or ask about math
to someone who's in advance to like
algebra or calculus i think if people
constantly complain about their rights
being taken away it's going to devolve
into their rights being gone as opposed
to actually projecting their rights
then you realize oh your rights are
there because you projected them not
because it was written on some paper and
given to you from somewhere else you
created that in your in your behavior
let's read some more super chats common
cure says chloe is the anti-candy also
ian do you play deep rock galactic i do
hit me up on steam
i'm mr clear bro rock and stone rock and
stone
frank taylor says tim listen to chloe
she is smarter than you i think i've
noticed that
agreed with many of her points and said
actually you're right points that's why
i referenced jordan peterson as i'm a
big fan because for him to be willing to
just be like i'm i was wrong about that
i'm like man that is that's strength
that's awesome yeah yeah
someone mentioned we had a bunch of
chinese bots in chats dare they get out
what's up dudes
all right let's see we got
caitlin clark says first time donation
your guest is spreading the right
messages thank you for by providing a
platform for spiritually aware and
intelligent voices oh absolutely i like
that this has been a great conversation
awesome
all right
andrew fetter says hey tim and crew hope
someone has lifted the man stone since
my visit ah yes he gave us the atlas
stone oh big one the rite of passage if
you lift it you're a man oh yeah i have
not lived regarding the office
censorship critical theorists need to
attack any exploits of their weaknesses
it's how to influence culture wait say
it again critical theorists need to
attack any exploits of their weaknesses
oh anything that might mock or belittle
them yeah so when you watch the office
and you laugh at the ridiculousness or
whatever yeah
i think he's right
bruce a two says ian get at her now
i don't know what that means but also i
think she's right the bible is highly
symbolic and has many allusions to
science of all types from a time when
they supposedly didn't have science
that's true i agree with interesting
things that is very interesting i was i
was reading a a long time ago a
scientific analysis of some of the rules
in the bible and to why they why why
they were yeah
like why you weren't supposed to eat
pork or whatever yeah because they were
dirty diseased animals
yeah and it would get you sick and so
they were like
don't eat it yeah you know
all right let's see we got here we'll do
uh we'll try and get as many as we can
but we've gone way over but it's it's
awesome yeah this is good
cody black says first time super chat i
listen every day and love the show
trying to get my so sarah to watch as
well please help me sell the show to her
if you get her to watch it would leave
me speechless
i would i would tell her she should
watch it because i'm here and i can
always use the female company tonight
when chloe's here so have her join me
that's right
martin the panda says the fundamental
problem is an increasing lack of faith
in something outside the human
experience when there's nothing greater
than yourself to answer life's big
questions it's much easier to see
yourself as divine and those against you
as evil
interesting well
i would have agreed halfway with that i
think that i do believe that human
beings are divine but that doesn't i
don't mean that in the i think that
human beings are you know i'm spiritual
so i think that human beings are made in
the image of the divine
um and this idea that comes from genesis
is like being made in the image of god
is like something that i
subscribe to i don't think that's the
problem but i do think that
that doesn't mean
um actually john vervicky has this has
this interesting riff
that has influenced my
thoughts on the idea of the sacred what
do you mean when you call something
sacred do you mean
sacred as inexhaustible as then the
human being is inexhaustible you'll
never be able to fully grasp
the deep essence of the human being
or do you mean sacredness as perfection
and perfection
if something is perfect
then it's
static and non-dynamic and therefore
dead that's not it yeah and like an idol
you know so it's perfection or
inexhaustible yeah tim you actually
mentioned that the universe was perfect
the other night and i think it was more
that it's inexhaustible i think it's
inexhaustible that's it because i've
been thinking a lot about that that
phrase what do you mean we were talking
about the perfection of the universe and
how it just functions so perfectly but
how you're defining perfection is that
it's static
and the changing imperfections in the
universe seem to give it this
inexhaustible quality this
and what's the word death of the
universe is as far as we know yeah
and inevitability yeah if untouched but
of course we we are the warden well so
this is this is this is one thing i've
talked i think the expansion of space
right now
it's beyond our understanding how to
rever reverse this
but it's entirely possible at least
well i could be wrong about this but i
believe it's possible
life in the universe comes to a point
where sure there's heat death of the
universe but maybe we create extremely
advanced machines extremely advanced ai
super intelligent that just floats for
billions of years until it interacts
with that one electron and absorbs it
and then just keeps going without you
know losing any and then it may take
trillions of years but it's eventually
collecting all the matter and still
functioning as some form of complex
system
or maybe by that point we learn how to
collapse and control space-time and
the universe just we just reef [ __ ] you
know that whatever's created i hope i'm
gone by that time yeah
martin the panda has an additional he
says i was an atheist for 37 years and
realized that's not what i wanted to
leave my girls i began attending church
for philosophical reasons and now i have
faith and a better understanding of
purpose and place there's something more
than just us
very jordan peterson moment yeah yeah
yeah
jeremy mcdude says i have a theory
regarding independent voters thinking
the economy is good they live in
non-blue hellholes and don't act and
don't actually see many effects of the
awful economy of 2021
even then you should at least see how
much you pay in gas yeah seriously
all right agent juice cartoon says glad
to see chloe on the show many la
animation groups are too identitarian i
want to start an animation group with
merit professionalism and equality
instead would love to see if toe could
help make that
a group
theory
yes group a reality hmm
interesting i don't know much about
animation or that space wonder what's i
would be interested in knowing more
about what's going on
yeah yeah do you have a general help
email line that you would have people
contact or is that well people can fill
out like a form on our website if
they're interested in like learning more
and getting more information yeah i got
in touch with you nice yes
waffles sensei says chloe glad you came
to talk about this stuff with a bunch of
political commentators i think your
organization will be the most
influential because you keep your
politics very milk toast that makes
people have to address the ideas on the
merit yeah
that's good yeah that's a strength
there's probably a bunch of uh
doctor strange ones so many i see them
yes
are they well actually yeah pretty much
saint matthew says tim your marvel idea
wouldn't work there was no multiverse
yet as per
that's
loki
wrong though
because
uh have you seen loki
no
so um
instantly
the moment that they uh i guess um well
i i forgot the woman's name already so
what was her name sophie or something i
don't know she killed um
the one that remains or whatever
instantly the timelines fracture so it's
like even if there is only one sacred
timeline in fact the loki timeline where
there's only one timeline the sacred
timeline
actually exists in a superposition of
infinity with all the other timelines
just somewhat isolated from them because
there as he mentions the moment you kill
me there will instantly be all these
other you know conquerors who will be
around you so
it did exist
that's why
i think there's an issue with the loki
show trying to do the sacred timeline
because we've already referenced the
multiverse and other timelines and they
have no explanation for how this
interferes with those ideas other than
to say
it was inevitable that the one that
remains would be killed shattering the
sacred timeline creating infinite
timelines and changing the past and thus
all those alternate universe could have
existed anyway and the show what if
actually explores these other universes
which exist anyway
anyway i have no i did not follow that
yeah it was like another language but
i'm learning yeah
so
speaking of marvel yeah in the loki show
there's only one timeline okay because
there's an organization called that like
what's it called the tva or whatever
time timeline variance authority they
destroy any any uh multiverse branch
okay so anything that deviates from
their scripted timeline they go there
they destroy and they send it to like a
a death dimension
however
at the end a female loki variant
kills the guy enforcing it
then the entire second timeline shatters
into infinite universes
which means that the whole thing is in a
state of flux of back and forth okay
because then there's a war between the
one that remains
one maintains sacred universe which
instantly collapses because it's time
there's no there's no past or future so
it's
still
i'm sorry they all exist before the
prime universe and after the prime
universe and during the prime universe
because time is a torus of motion
all right we'll just read one more
because we've gone a bit way over
a bit way over
okay mickey mouse says ian rights aren't
the ability to defend
to defend oneself they are what gives
you the moral high ground when you have
to defend yourself yes rights are what
give you the
the legal essentially legal authority in
this moral moral laws
are not morality um
wait what yeah i agree with that just
because something's legal doesn't mean
it's moral
right right oh but you think rights give
you are basically your justification for
doing the morally just thing yeah yeah
probably i agree with them right on well
thank you friends for hanging out this
friday night you effectively got a bonus
segment i guess we normally don't do it
but um you can follow the show at
timcast irl you can check out
youtube.comcastcastle
for all the vlogs we're putting up and
you can watch what we're doing on a
day-to-day basis and the funny thing is
you can watch me somehow in between all
the work i'm doing tending to the
chickens because it's just non-stop work
all day every day you can follow me
personally at timcast become a member at
timcast.com support our journalism do
you want to shout out your social media
or anything else sure
check out theory of enchantment dot com
you can follow me on twitter at cvaldery
also uh enchant theory you can also
follow me
on instagram at cvaldery and theory of
enchantment
any other wisdom
um i would say
make with my business to know thyself
which is the hardest thing to do in the
world
thank you that's why i like to make
internet videos and watch myself be an
idiot on tv i can't deny it anymore
after that
uh also you can follow me in crossland
if you if you want to but do it yeah
thank you
i appreciated chloe's wisdom tonight it
is very rare to find a very wise and
philosophical lady
very short supply so we need to we need
to bring that back yes we do we need to
make it cool again yeah excited to see
it coming back you guys should follow me
on twitter at sarah patchoulits as i
attempt to have more followers and sour
patch kids i'm 5000 away so please join
me
we have a new members only show coming
up very soon we're not necessarily going
to have a set schedule but it's going to
be called the green room and the idea is
when guests arrive there's actually
about 10 to 15 minutes where there's fun
and weird conversations when steve
bannon came
and he met andreas who said you know
ian's friend
exerts you've seen his shirt on me
before andreas was saying so many crazy
things to steve bannon but steve bannon
was into it and you know andres is
talking about transhumanism and like
cyber marxism or whatever and like
after after the show bannon's like who
is that that guy he's a genius yeah and
i thought it was hilarious but there's
there like you know it's a very very
weird
i don't know but anyway the idea is
there's a lot of people downstairs that
are hanging out in the green our green
room is downstairs so when people come
in
a lot of the guests will meet people and
so we're actually gonna have like a 10
to 15 minute members only video where
you can see the um
non
you know cycle like news cycle kind of
conversations you might hear
conversation just about chickens you
know people could talk about their pets
and it's just like off the cuff and it's
something we can do to make more content
for the members and then we'll actually
flesh that out and make make something
more with it so that's coming very very
soon maybe even in the next day or so
we've got to get the website ready for
it so thanks for hanging out everybody
it's been a blast
youtube.comcastcastle and we'll see you
all next time bye guys
you